This is Jocko podcast number one 84 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good evening. I go. Good evening.
It's been awhile since we've done some Q and a and there's been a lot of
questions so let's get into it. Ready to go to it. Okay.
Question number one Jocko. I'm having issues playing the game,
quote unquote at work.
I'm quiet and friendly but I prefer to work hard rather rather than stand out
and talk.
I found I have trouble forming more personal connections with my boss and
coworkers. What are your tips?
So look, when I talk about playing the game,
I'm not talking about the fact that you have to change your entire personality
profile to start to connect with people. That's not what I'm saying.
You don't have to go from being someone that's what they say,
quiet and friendly to.
You don't have to become some chatty extrovert running around making small talk
with everybody. And on top of that,
there is a little bit of a statement here that says, you know,
I'd rather work hard as if there's,
these are mutually exclusive things, which they are certainly not.
So this being forming relationships with people and playing the game does not
interfere with your work at all.
I'm not saying that you sit around and talk when there's work to be done,
but
there's going to be natural breaks in whatever you're doing.
There's going to be moments where skip the action pauses and you get a chance to
connect with somebody. So that's fine. So, so what are some tips that,
how would you do this? Sorry, I thought about this.
Have you want to start with something small? Right. But you want to engage,
this is the key point. I don't just want to throw something at you.
I want to talk at you.
And besides when it's much easier just to let someone talk about themselves.
So the, what I'm, what my advice in this particular question is,
is to tell them something about yourself,
like something minor about yourself.
But then that kind of ties into something that you can ask them and then they
can talk to you. Because most people like to talk about themselves.
So you ask them a question about themselves and then you go,
so you know something, something maybe something slightly related to work.
So it's not just some random statement that you're making, you know,
s you'd say,
you know what we did yesterday at work here reminded me of something.
Right. It reminded me of something else.
And then maybe it reminded me of a movie, Hey,
you know what we were doing yesterday reminded me of this movie.
Have you seen that movie? And at least you're going to get, well no,
cause I don't watch a lot of movies or no, I haven't seen that movie. Or Oh,
I've seen that movie. If it's a popular movie,
but chances are they're seeing it. You know what I mean?
And all of a sudden you've got a little bit
of a conversation going and that's all we're looking for.
We're not looking to turn into like chatty, catty, we're just trying to build,
build relationships with people. So you know who they are. So they,
they know who you are. That's what we're talking about. Nothing crazy.
Start small build from there. Yeah. Yeah. Pretty straight forward. Yeah. In, in,
through that building process. What it Kinda found is one,
and I guess maybe this is a little tactical thing you can kind of throw out
whenever, but you know,
and you know when people give you advice or they tell you something about
themselves that something, I don't know, whatever, whatever the story is, right.
And maybe some strategy they use to do Xyz.
It can be super small if you let them know that you've remembered like in the
future, later on when you see him again, you say,
I remembered what you said last week, you know, tie it in this yet.
And it can be the smallest that that purple belt, Jujitsu,
mental, Jujitsu, I like it.
It can be the smallest thing and it just makes me feel good so that that person
will just essentially feel more open with you. Like, oh my gosh,
I'm [inaudible] pays this guy really pays attention to me. Oh yeah.
Makes them feel valuable. All that stuff just on that small level, you know?
So as far as building little relationships,
I'd say that's a cool thing to kind of remember to do. If he can't, I tend,
it's a cool kind of thing to remember too. All right,
next question Jocko.
May I ask your advice for addressing a cowboy quote unquote mentality among
teams working in dangerous environments?
How would you shift the culture to kill complacency too aggressively identify
and mitigate risk as a point of professional pride?
Okay.
This is something that we'll definitely saw it in the seal team seat all the
time in the civilian sector, you know, construction companies, power companies,
companies where people are doing dangerous work, right? Policing,
firefighting, anything, anything that has any element of danger.
You definitely see this. And like I said, certainly it's on the seal teams.
And the answer to this is a common answer for many leadership situations is you
have to explain why. So let me put it in a little context.
What you have to do is you have to say, Hey,
let me explain to you what happens when someone gets hurt or injured on this
job. Okay. First of all,
we get the loss of that person on the job that the job that we're working on,
the project that we're working on, it falls back.
There's paperwork that has to be filed, which by the way,
the paperwork hurts the progress of our project as well.
Our budget's impacted because now we've got to bring someone else on board.
We've got to train them.
We take a reputational hit as a company.
Right? What, what kind of a,
what kind of a company can't do a job without getting someone hurt, right?
I mean, this isn't a high bar. It's not a very high bar to say, Hey,
can you complete this task without getting someone injured?
Yeah. And all of a sudden we got a g, we got, Hey, you know what? Our company,
we don't, we get a lot of people hurt. Well,
what does that tell you about the company? It's a reputational hit.
Who are you going to hire? You're not gonna hire.
The one that's got people getting hurt all the time. So there's that.
The and what does that do?
What does that do to your reputation in terms of everything else?
Because if you're gonna a bunch of people hurt,
how can I expect you to keep your timelines?
How can I expect you to stay on budget? So
it's those things. It's those,
that kind of reputation that you get if you are getting people hurt.
And then also what does it do? What does it say about your team?
If you've got people getting hurt, and again, this is what I'm talking about,
a conversation that you're having with the group, with the team. You're saying,
look, what kind of a team are we? If we got people getting hurt,
what does that say about us? It says we're lack lackadaisical.
It says we're complacent. It says we don't pay attention.
What does it say about our leadership? If we got guys getting hurt,
what does that say about our leadership says we don't care about our people,
which by the way it says we don't care about our people. It means,
it says we don't care about our job. It says we don't care about our reputation.
Says what you do. We just don't damn care.
And what does it say about you? The individual,
what you know what it says about you an individual. If you get hurt,
you know what it says about you. You're a knucklehead and you got hurt.
You couldn't follow the procedures, you didn't follow the procedures.
You thought you were smart and you got complacent. Now you got hurt.
So these are the things when I talk about explaining why those are where I'm
going to start and now I'm going to explain and connect the dots so that the
purse, the individual,
see that someone getting hurt is actually the least professional thing that you
can do from a leadership perspective. If I let one of my guys get hurt, um,
that's just, that's just
Lily's professional thing I can do from an individual contributor perspective.
If I'm getting hurt, guess what? I didn't follow procedures. Okay, look,
are there accidents that happened? Yes, there are.
But what I'm saying is if you get an accident that could have been prevented,
that should have been prevented. And I as an individual let it happen.
That is absolutely my fault.
It's like when you've got a guy getting ready for an MMA fight and they get cut,
they weren't wearing head gear and it's like, look, I get it.
But that was dumb and I've had that happen. I mean,
I've had it happen with my fighters. I've seen it happen. All kinds of,
it happens in the UFC all the time, right? You've got a fight coming up.
You're going to fight for the title for the UFC title.
You're going to make possibly millions of dollars.
You're going to be the champion of the world. Oh, two weeks out, got a cut,
got a cut on my head, help, you know, blew out my ACL doing take down defense.
Right? Look, I get it. Accidents happen.
But what was really happening right at that moment?
Was it a random accident or we were doing something that we shouldn't have been
doing. So if we start to lean, look,
having accidents is actually an unprofessional thing to do.
It's a weak thing to do. It's a bad thing to do. When we let it happen,
it hurts everyone, not just the individual involved.
That's the attitude that we, we kind of come with, you know, we had the,
in the uh, in the,
in the navy you have like alcohol programs,
so hey, this is our program for you know, alcohol,
here's how we're trying to combat having people have alcohol related incident.
And when I was at trade Ed,
they had someone come in to like give us a talk about alcohol and then,
and then when they got done, the guy says, okay, you know, sir,
I was the guy in charge. He goes, what's your alcohol policy?
And I didn't have one and I didn't have one. And I was like, okay, hey cool.
I'll come up with one. Here's the alcohol policy. If you get hurt
or sorry, if you get drunk and you can't,
if you get drunk and you get in trouble or you get in a fight or you get
arrested or you get a DUI and you take time away from being deployable,
you are doing owl cadas job for them.
There's the alcohol policy. So now all of a sudden it's not like hey cool,
we're, we're, we're like Rah Rah. No. All of a sudden, hey man,
do we want to help the enemy by taking ourselves off the battlefield.
I mean there's nothing more that al Qaeda wants than for this seal to be
arrested for DUI and non deployable.
You just did al-Qaeda's job for you. Yeah.
So that's the kind of thing that I'm going to build the culture around. Yeah.
And that's the same thing you can do with people that are,
have that cowboy mentality.
You shift it so that that cowboy mentality becomes the thing that hurts our
reputation, that hurts our,
that hurts the company reputation and it hurts our individual personal
reputation as a man.
I couldn't even prevent my,
my shift from getting hurt from having someone get injured. Yeah,
so that's what you like. It feeds into their professional pride,
especially when you use the word unprofessional. No. Yeah. You know, like,
yeah, man, I knew you knew what you're doing on that one.
And then on the flip side, if you say consummate professional, right? Ooh,
that's a good uncle. If ea, if your man, you can do it,
doesn't even matter the job you can do.
You can have your own lawn mowing business when you're 13 years old.
If you're, someone says, Hey, that guy, that kid's a consummate professional.
You're like, hell yeah. Hell yeah. I'm going to have to push back a little bit.
I don't know if there's too many.
I don't know if there's too many situations where you would say a 13 year old
lawn mower.
Now we know that mark the way the where your kid is heavily involved in
lawnmowing with marks, meticulous mowing. Yes. Yes sir. He is.
But even, I don't even know if I'd call him a consummate professional.
I wouldn't either. But if you, if you were just working towards it,
if you were to do so, mark would feel really good if you said,
that's what I'm saying is you can't be just throwing words around. Okay.
You can't just throw around consummate professional about low moments.
Now let's say the guy was a greenskeeper like on a golf course. Sure.
Now that person could be a consummate professional cause he's got to dial stuff
in and then maybe,
I guess you get to a certain level of just straight landscaping where, Oh,
you know what? There was a water, there was a, the pipe exploded. Oh,
Jocko came in. He had that whole thing resodded receded.
Took him four hours. That guy is a consummate professional,
so I guess I'll take it back. Well, I'm just saying reserve it.
Don't play with it. Okay. Don't play with that. Flying that finger on. Yeah,
exactly right. Yeah. Well, um, the,
the drip and that, that was very clever on your part. What was,
when you said you're doing okay, does job for you because think about it.
I mean, you know,
there's nothing worse for a guy in the military is you are actually helping the
enemy right now. And then how you say it like you named names,
you know it's not like you said the enemy, which I get. That's good too.
But it's way better to be like you're doing a new name the the PR because JP
will say that to right. Where he'll be like, um,
there was a sign or something about a sign or maybe he'll just say it.
He'll be like, your your enemy. Thanks you for not giving 100% today. Great.
Remember that one and it's good. That's a good one. And it sounds cool too.
I get it, but it is real general.
So you hear that 10 times or every day or whatever you like. Okay, cool.
It sounds cool, but it won't really affect your professional pride all the time.
Sometimes it does something, but if you name the enemy, you know,
like if you have some adversary, you know, and they thank you, that person,
whatever John Smith, you know, for not giving 100%, you know,
it might feed into, so you saying [inaudible] thanks you, you know,
for getting arrested. So I'm like, yeah man, think about it from the flip side,
right? What if you think of like an al Qaeda fighting team, right.
And one of them gets cut, like one of their effective fighters gets caught,
I don't know, doing something that they don't like gambling,
going to a strip club, I don't know, whatever. And they say, Hey,
you're not allowed to fight anymore for us. So he gets like exiled or whatever.
[inaudible] that's sweet. We want them to do that.
We might even send them some strip club recommendation. You see what I'm saying?
So it's literally, you're literally doing that literally. Yeah.
That's good. Clever, clever.
All right, next question. Hi. Juggle.
You answered a question about complainer's and said you'd listened to the,
because well it should be listened to them, right? You know,
you said you would listen to them because you can learn what the problems are.
I like it and people like to be heard.
But how do you handle chronic complainer's
the type of people who become cancerous? I'm a huge fan of extreme honesty.
Should take thanks for your time. Uh, yeah. This, this is the cause, once again,
for my favorite, my favorite general remedy in,
in leadership situations is you take this person and you put them in charge,
put him in charge. Yeah.
And this is one of those classic things where someone says, hey,
why are we even doing it this way? And you say, Oh, Echo, you don't like that.
Cool. Why don't you come up with a plan and you go execute it however you want.
And, and that does one of two things. Either they, they say,
OK and they step up and then they have to figure out how hard the job,
the task is. And they have to get it done. And it's,
they learn from it and they get humbled by it and they recognize the, the, the,
the burden of responsibility that a leader actually has, which is all good.
Or they just say, no, no, no.
And they stopped playing this cause they don't want to get tasked with anything
again. Now what you gotta be careful with it.
A lot of these answers that I give you could go like in the wrong direction.
So what I mean by that is echo says, hey,
I don't like we do the way we're doing this. And I go, okay,
well then you're in charge. You know what I mean? I do it like that.
It's a punishment.
It's a punitive thing that isn't absolutely not what I'm talking about. I said,
you know what? I go, you're pointing out some good stuff.
You're pointing out some definite shortfalls in the way that this is happening.
I'll tell you what,
why don't you actually just take responsibility for this and you can run this
task and you can make this happen. Cause I, I think, you know,
just based on some of the things you've pointed out already,
I'm not even calling them complaints based on some of the things you pointed out
already. I think you could probably improve upon our process quite a bit.
You know, so you've gotta be careful.
I'm not talking about being a jerk to someone. Yeah.
I'm talking about act and this is the thing is like, it's like there's, there's,
there's this thing where what I'm doing, I'm not just playing the game.
You ever, you ever have ever told us in Jujitsu, I'm like, Hey,
if you want to set me up with the choke so that you can get my arm,
you have to actually do the choke. You have to actually apply the pressure.
If you don't apply the pressure, I'm not defending it.
My name's not going to go where you want it. You have to actually do it.
And if I don't defend it the way you expect me to, then you just choked me.
Yeah. It's the same thing here. I'm not saying you just say,
well why don't you do it then? No, you have to actually say, hey listen,
I think this is what's going on. I think you have some good points.
Why don't you take lead on this? And we'll see if you can, you know,
remedy the situation. Cause I think you've got a pretty good chance of doing it.
This isn't, I'm not doing this as a punitive thing.
I'm doing it because it's the best thing for the team.
You've got a legitimate complaint, you've got a bunch of them.
Let's get you in a position where you can sort some of those things out.
So yeah, so that's, that's that when you get people that are complaining,
you know, first of all, hear them out and maybe that's good enough, right? Hey,
listen to them. And, and, and once again, I'm not saying you listen him while
your brain is elsewhere and you're not thinking of,
you actually listen to what they're saying. You're engaged. You really do.
Go for the choke. Go for it. Listen to what they're saying.
Maybe there's some solutions you can come up with.
But then if that doesn't work and even after they,
even after you listen to them and you explain to them why things aren't the way
they want, they still want to complain. It complained about it. Cool.
That's fine. Awesome. Why don't you take lead on this then?
That way you can sort out some of these issues. So appreciate it.
And like Lafe said that one time,
it's kind of hard to complain about a plan when it's your plan. Yeah.
That is the truth. Yeah, makes sense. God, I'm so stupid.
Here's this and sucks that I came up with. But the, yeah, the um,
chronic complaining cause you could kind of, I mean,
people who complain a lot, you, you, you, it's easy to be like, oh,
they're chronic complaints. Right. But if there's constantly,
we'll say chronic problems that might induce chronic complaining.
I'm not saying that's the case, obviously,
because I know there is such thing as chronic complaints.
100% but at the very least, like I say, Oh yeah,
put him in charge of something or, or listen to them and they'll put, you know,
listen to what they're complaining about or whatever,
that you might actually get turned on to all these solvable problems. You know?
And if you, if look, if you make someone take lead in a, in a situation, right.
And you know how it's Kinda like,
that's Kinda that concept of like taking an extreme ownership.
And then what if they'd do like say, yeah,
it is your fault and then you get all mad, you know, kind of thing. It's like,
aw, you didn't really do that. It's like,
so if you put someone else in charge of something,
you're really putting them in charge.
Like what if they run and what if they take lead and they solve all the
problems? Awesome. Right? Yes, exactly right.
So you don't treat this action or this discourse as like some thing to get back
at the complaint. It's not just, it's not just a setup. Yeah, it's a real move.
A real deal. And you know, that's you just,
you just made this point that I made,
which is one of the best leadership tools that is completely overlooked by
people all the time, is very, very simple to do.
And that's just to listen to what people are saying. I know it sounds crazy,
but I run into all the time leaders in all kinds of levels,
all kinds of situations.
And the biggest problem they have is they don't even listen to anyone else.
They won't listen. Yeah. So when you're in a leadership position,
try this, be quiet and listen to what people are saying.
Listen to what they're complaining about.
Listen to what suggestions they have listened to, what advice they give.
Listen to their recommendations. Listen, just listen.
Sometimes you're going to be in a much better spot. Yeah.
And even like you saying that out loud sounds real obvious. You know? But it's,
man, it's not, cause even a lot of times like if you don't listen,
I'm thinking about myself, like all the many trillions,
trillions of times that I haven't listened when I should have.
Most of the time. Most of the time we'll say, I mean to not listen.
I don't mean to be like, it's not like I'm like hearing noise and be like, oh,
you don't know what you're talking about. You're dumb.
You know what you say doesn't mean anything. It's not that.
It's more that I'm like focused so hard on what I'm thinking or my way or
whatever. Like I'm just so just of course naturally to mind.
I've been thinking about it for years now, you know, kind of thing.
So I'm so dumb.
Basically dug in to myself on my own thing that I'm not and I'm just not paying
attention that much. You know?
I'm like working so hard and down this tunnel that like I can't look out of the
tunnel kind of thing. So you don't really mean to,
but when you're in the situation it's like, it's not that easy. You know it's,
it's, and you know what it is. Also, it's detachment, right?
When you're talking, you're talking in a step back to tach.
Listen to what people are saying. I do this all the time. Do this all the time.
It's such a, it's such an easy move. Yeah. If you'd sit your remember move,
you just watch, you just listen. Even like, can you get to do this?
We'll be like, oh the person wants to move around a bunch of cool.
I'll let them move around. Let's see where they're going.
I'm just going to listen to their moves, you know? Yeah.
And that's a good way to put it, man. Just listen to their moves. Just listen.
And Yeah. If you primarily focus on that listening,
then like you habitually be able to do it way better. Cause like again,
like back to the, it's not like you're not doing it with malicious intent,
you know, you're not shutting them down.
It's almost like you already like interrupters. Right. You know,
chronic interrupters. People interrupt you all the time. Some of the time,
a lot of time, whatever we'll say half of the time estimate there,
it doesn't feel like they're doing it because they don't want to hear what you
have to say. Sometimes it's that for sure. But sometimes they, it's almost like,
it's almost like they have this tone of like, Dang, I don't think I finished.
My point is good as I want it to almost explain that to them for themselves
because they're so committed to their message and what they've been thinking the
whole time, and if you're not signing right onto it, it's, man,
I must not set it clear enough. You see what I'm saying?
I had to like tighten up my kids on just straight.
They just wouldn't let each other talk. It's just interrupt, interrupt,
interrupt, and I think it was, yeah, it was my son for sure,
and he looked at me and he goes, he's like a, he says, dad,
you're going to just be aggressive.
Our whole lives are now all of a sudden you're telling us just to sit back.
Oh, that was funny. Did you tell him that?
That's the dichotomy I said that's the dichotomy of course.
All right, next question. What is,
what is the most important issue you've ever changed your mind about
this is, you know, this is one of those things where I'm,
I'm sure this is one of those questions where I should have like some answer
about some specific subject or something. You know what I mean? Like I can see,
I know what answer is desired. I know what type of answers desired,
but the reality is, you know, for me,
taking ownership
of things, right? This and this,
this wasn't really like I changed my mind to where what I used to say,
I'm going to blame everyone and then all of a sudden I said, you know what?
That's not the right policy to have. I need to Tart to extreme ownership.
I didn't do that, but it was just a,
a thing that built and developed inside my brain.
And I think it's the most,
the most important thing that I've ever sort of recognized or conclusion that
I've come to. That's not a change,
but I'm sure at some point my attitude wasn't like,
I'll just take ownership of that, which it is now. But at some point, you know,
I'd say, well that's not really my responsibility. You know what I mean?
Of course.
That's a natural thing to say and I'll tell you what the next,
and this is interesting, but the other,
and this one's kind of more of a more of a,
I can pin it down a little bit closer to an answer that someone would like and
this is, once again, it's going to be a little bit
a little bit strange.
But the other thing is the dichotomy of leadership. And this is the,
this is the thing about the dichotomy of leadership.
And I actually was thinking, I actually didn't,
didn't really recognize this until the last muster and I was,
as I was thinking about the dichotomy of leadership,
maybe it was off of a question maybe. I think it was actually before. No,
actually it was before we even started.
I was just like reviewing notes and thinking about the dichotomy of leadership
and,
and one of the most important things about that economy of leadership is that
the reason, the, the reason that I came to the conclusion,
the reason that I got to the dichotomy of leadership in getting there,
let me rephrase that then getting to a point where I said there's a dichotomy of
leadership.
What I had to do was I had to admit to myself that I was wrong about everything.
That's what I had to do in order for the,
for the idea of the dichotomy of leadership to, to,
to escape my brain, to get out, to get to,
to become a full thought, what I had to do,
I had to admit to myself that I was actually wrong about everything.
So I'll give you real easy examples.
One of my things that I used to tell guys all the time, you gotta be aggressive.
You gotta be aggressive.
That's how you got to be in order for the dichotomy of leadership.
I had to admit, you know what? Sometimes being aggressive doesn't work, right?
I used to say, you know what, as a leader you could have stayed up.
You've got gotta be loud. And then I realized, you know what,
there's I see leaders that are two that I had to admit that I was wrong about
that, that sometimes that was wrong.
I had to admit that I was wrong about keeping things simple.
Like you know what? This is one of the most fundamental laws of combat.
You got to keep things simple.
And then I had to admit that sometimes people keep things too simple.
Even this fact right here, right? In order to admit that I was wrong,
I had to be, I had
to be humble and I used to preach and I still preach humility as being like the
most important thing. But guess what?
There are people and there even me where there's p,
there's times and places where you can be too humble. Yeah.
And so this idea, this idea that there's a dichotomy to everything.
It's something that the original fought for me was,
it came from me having one sided opinion and then realizing that,
and I'm, I'm almost positive. I don't remember crystal clear,
but I'm almost positive that the original thought that I realized there was a
dichotomy to was being aggressive and,
and again this was,
this is all kind of coming to fruition as I'm teaching guys at trade at and leaf
was running the junior officer training course and I used to give them the soul
and I remember writing, you know, I remember if it saved myself,
you know what I got to tell guys that they can go too far with being aggressive
and they can go too far with barking orders and they, and I just,
it like that's where it came from.
And if I wouldn't have been able to change my mind right.
Cause that's what this question was changing my mind about something.
The biggest thing probably ever in my life was understanding that just about
every characteristic that a person can have that a leader can have can go too
far and can become a negative characteristic.
So that's probably the biggest thing that I've changed my mind on. Hmm.
Interesting. Yeah, that aggressive one. That makes sense. Cause like, yeah,
aggressive being aggressive like is one of the more effective ways to straight
up quote unquote get things done. For sure. Right. Do it and it'll be done.
Do it. You know, don't wait. Don't hesitate. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh there's a,
there's a problem in a building.
Let's sit back and wait until that problem starts. No,
like you've got to be aggressive. Yeah. But then if you're in digits,
we'll teach you all kinds of lessons like this where if you're going to spring a
trap on somebody or something, animal person, whatever,
what's the best type of type of person that you can catch with a trap?
Probably an aggressive one. You know,
like they can set themselves up to get trapped if they're like aggressive,
you know, like an animal who's real hungry, you know,
hesitating. Like if an animal is like hesitant, you know, just hesitant,
maybe sees things develop a little bit before they take a certain action or
whatever, that'd be harder to trap. Yeah. Generally, yeah.
And this is the thing that's,
this is what makes humility important is it's hard to come to grips with the
dichotomy of leadership because if you don't have the humility to sometimes say,
you know what? You're right that you know what? I am wrong. Yeah.
This the hard on this plan isn't
what I thought it should be. Yeah. So hard to do that.
That's why it's hard to really get a grip on the dichotomy leadership and that's
what makes it so important.
That's what makes it the answer to so many questions.
And sometimes people will come like, you know, someone will come up and say,
they'll have their counterpoint to what I'm saying.
And I'll tell you right now, let's let me think about of a,
of a situation where you have to provide a counterpoint. If I,
somebody comes to me and says, you know what?
Being aggressive isn't always good. Sometimes if you're aggressive,
all you do is you, you run to your death.
Now an egotistical Jocko would say,
negative. You're wrong. I'm right.
And I would dig in in that position. And when you dig in in position,
you can't maneuver anymore. So I'm actually stuck.
So this is a classic thing to do. Also, when, when,
when I'm arguing with somebody, if you come to me and you say,
I think we should do this, you know, method B, I say,
I don't say no cause I think we should do it meth today. That's what I think.
And you think we should do it? Method B, you're going to be,
I think we should do this. Method B, I think you're wrong. You know,
you know what I say? Okay, well I think you've got some good points on method B.
Oh, all of a sudden, you know,
all of a sudden we're in a totally different scenario.
I just totally flipped the script on you and I, you know what I'm saying?
As I said, you don't, there's some good points that you have.
If you watch people debate,
if it's really a little slick move,
but you don't see politicians do it because they're so dug in,
they can never think they're wrong and they can never,
and then what they also are afraid of, they're afraid.
If they admit they're wrong about something, they'll look bad.
Whereas if they said, you know what, that's a good point.
That's actually a good point. I'm going to need consider that.
I've never really thought of that viewpoint before. You know what,
I'm going to assess that. But I guys I think you got, I got,
I think there's some validity to what you just said.
When's the last time you heard a politician say that? I don't. Yeah, I'll never,
I don't think. And then what happens is, and in this day and age, the,
the supporters of that politician, they, they don't, they don't,
they don't recognize the valid point either. It's just
oh yeah.
So we get people that aren't thinking end to end and it's very hard to hold
dichotomies in your head that this can be right. And that can be right.
There's an aggressive approach and there's a non aggressive approach.
There's a direct approach and there's an indirect approach and both of them can
be functional. It's really hard to get, get a grip on that.
And yet it's the answer to so many questions. It's the answer to the person,
this subordinate that comes to you and says, we should not be doing it this way.
If your reaction isn't too diametrically opposed what they're saying.
But instead to actually take their side and say, oh,
I agree with you've got some really good points.
Let's see how this would play out.
Talk me through it. Look, you can't even know. You're like, wow. You know,
you know, it's like, it's like an, it's like an, it's like a move.
It's like a Jujitsu move. Yeah. And it works. Yeah.
So there, there are some things I've changed, changed my mind on about
my mind is opened though. Yeah. I will change my mind if,
if new evidence presents itself, I'll change my mind in a heartbeat.
Let's do it. Present me with new evidence. What about like,
um, well I would think anyway after kind of thinking about it where, yeah,
you, I think, I think generally speaking, we do kind of respect someone who can,
who can change their mind and we all see it once people's digging into their
opinion, you know, and saying all kinds of weird,
wacky stuff to try to defend yourself themselves and you're like, don't worry,
we're talking about kind of thing. You see it as clear.
So like it seems obvious like, yeah, you should change your mind when,
or at least open up your mind in, in that, like how you said, um, hey,
I'll give that some consideration. I'll look into it. And if you're right,
shoot, I think you're right. I think that's a better way to do it or whatever,
whatever the case is. But the,
and then I guess technically there's a dichotomy to where you can't do that too
much because if you're always changing your mind with like, you know, like,
like a, I don't know, we'll say up a politician. Yeah.
Every time the opposing view or some other view comes in and you're like, Dang,
I didn't look at it like that or I didn't. Maybe I'll look back in there.
We're looking to that more. We'll do it again and again and again. It's like,
Brad, does this guy know anything? Cause guess what you're talking about what?
There's a dichotomy. Yeah. That's what Andy,
if you go too far and you change your opinion all the time and then you become
indecisive and so that doesn't work if you're,
so if you're the other side of the spectrum and you're completely dug in and you
never change your mind, that doesn't work either. Where do you need to do?
What do you need to do? You need to balance the dichotomies,
the dichotomies between being flexible and inflexible.
If you become ultra flexible where you're just going with whatever at anyone
saying that's not good. Yeah. You need to find the middle ground.
That's what the dichotomy of leadership is. Yeah.
But it's hard for people to comprehend that.
It's hard for people to see that where they draw that line.
Yes. That gives, they think, well you know, I,
I'll never changed my opinion on this. Okay. You just told me where you stand.
Yeah. I'm not sure I liked that very much.
Cause new new information can come to light. Yeah. Yeah, that's true.
Yeah. That's a where the, where they stand right in that dichotomy or whatever.
Cause I think part of, part of it, um, and it's part of it is like yeah,
they don't want to be wishy washy, you know,
but the other part or the other part of that is I'm saying if they always change
their mind, if they're so easily to be like, oh okay,
maybe we'll do it your way. Whatever flipper. Yeah. It,
I think they come off like they don't know anything for sure. Like to the soil.
If you don't know anything, she'd even be in that position.
Like I don't want you to be the congressman if you're,
if you don't know anything kind of thing. Right. That's the feeling. So,
and now with that,
that's the feeling that people are trying to avoid when they dig in.
They don't want to admit they're wrong.
Cause if I admit I'm wrong and that means for what I didn't know, you know,
kind of thing. So it's like no bro, you don't,
you don't draw the line right there. You draw, draw the line,
couple of steps down the road. Yeah. Be Open a little bit yourself.
Some room to maneuver. Yeah. Yeah. Again, room to maneuver.
Next question.
How does one detach when getting personally attacked and take extreme ownership
with false claims?
And what does one do once when a subordinate always goes above the chain of
command instead of working out issues with the coworker? Okay.
This isn't the clearest question that I've ever received.
I'm going to try and I'm not sure if I completely understand it,
but I'm going to try and sort of answered to the best of my ability. Um,
I think what we're talking about here is that someone is telling me that
something is my fault and that is a false claim. Is that,
that's the question, right?
I think you're making a false claim and say like this is your responsibility.
Jocko. You were supposed to press record. Right? And it's false.
Cause I wasn't supposed to press record. Yeah.
Let's say or maybe like record was pressed like there's no issue,
you know. Well then why would, why would he,
why would that become a personal attack? Yeah. Yeah I guess so.
The personal attack is chocolate. You didn't press record. Yeah.
And now the question is what do I do them cause cause we both know who's in
charge of pressing record here. Yeah. Who is me. Okay.
So you're in charge of pressing record. If you all of a sudden we,
we are 40 minutes into,
into a podcast and we haven't pressed record to record has button has been
pressed and all of a sudden it comes to light and you say chocolate,
you didn't press record right now what this person is saying,
that's a false claim. Gotcha. That's not my responsibility.
It's truly not my responsibility and I'm not going to actually,
I should I be doing that. Yeah. And you know what I'm going to say,
you know what I'm going to say yes sir. I do. Which is, you know what,
it is my responsibility because I'm here. It's primarily my voice.
That's being recorded and from now on I will make sure that that gets recorded.
It's my fault. I will take care of it from now on. By the way. Now,
what is your job responsibilities in this whole podcast? Nothing.
You have nothing to do. If you're not pressing record, you're not nothing to do.
So how does that feel? Yeah, it doesn't feel good. It doesn't feel good.
You don't like that. But when I take away that responsibility,
you're actually gonna come and claw it back from me. You're going to say,
you know what? Actually, you know it was your fault when that happened,
but you know what? From now on, since you screwed it up,
I'm going to take ownership of it. And you know what I say? I said cool.
That's awesome. Yeah. Good point.
Since you are over there with the recorder and since you're a technical guy and
I'm not, that makes a lot of sense. Why don't we go with that from now on?
You own it. I shouldn't have dropped the ball last time. You know?
So that's that. There we go. I own it. I fix it. If, by the way,
if you don't want responsibility back, if you just say, cool, yeah,
you press record from now on. Okay, cool. I will. Yeah. And then guess what?
I'll start thinking about how much I need you around here. Yeah.
Cause really what else do you bring to the table in those buildings? All right,
so that's question number one. Uh,
the question number two, as far as detaching, sorry, I don't get emotional.
That's
if someone is blaming me, if someone is blaming me,
if you start blaming me or something,
I actually look at that right out of the gate.
I see that as a psychological victory for me because?
Because you're blaming me like you're blaming, you're not taking ownership.
I already won. I already won. So there's no,
I'm not getting emotional about that.
That's they're blaming me because they don't have the,
the wherewithal to actually take ownership themselves.
I see that as a weakness of theirs and I'm fine with it and that,
that's why I don't, I'm not going to,
I don't need to get emotional because I'm sitting there going, wow,
this person just served me up on a silver platter.
The fact that they don't want to take all the, their going to give it to me.
Are you kidding me? I'll take this all day long. Another thing is,
and I've said this before, I can't be respect.
I can't be disrespected by someone that doesn't even respect themselves. Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
You can't disrespect me if you don't even respect yourself if you're just,
you know, like a bum in the street is where the, where the thing came from.
You know, someone that's just, uh, you know,
a drunk bum laying in his own vomit and wants to, you know,
look at me and see you Luke Luke dirt bag.
It's like, okay dude. Yeah,
carry on with your day that you're not going to affect me.
So how in the same vein,
if how can I be disrespected by you when you tell me you and you blame me for
something when I realize what's happening right now is you don't even have
enough respect for yourself to take ownership of something. This is just a whim.
So that's the second part of it and I think the third part of the question is a
subordinate that that goes up the chain of command instead of working for
working out the issues with the coworker. That's pretty, pretty easy.
I'm not going to solve those problems for you. Oh,
you've got a problem down in the chain of command with your coworker, your peer,
and you guys aren't working it out and you want me to solve your problem? No,
you go figure it out and come back to me with a solution and now I'll do that a
couple times. If eventually they can't come up with a solution,
guess what I have, I have a problem,
I have a real problem and I will solve it and they're not going to like my
solution because it probably involves them. Neither one of them being there,
any more extreme case. But what I will do is I say, okay,
come and read me the facts. You really want me to make a decision about this.
Cool. I'll do it. But I always felt horrible. In fact,
I don't even know if I ever did this going to my boss to make a decision about
something that I should have agreed with my peer, because you know what,
I'd rather just, for me, I'd rather just say, Hey, you know what?
You want to do it your way. Eko, fun. You, let's go with it. It's close enough.
You, Oh, you want to take the lead? Cool. You take the lead, I'll support you.
No problem. That's what I'm here for. I want the team to win.
I know you're concerned about you add a note and that's fine. That's fine.
I'm here for the team, so let's do it your way so that it works out. Yeah.
Not going to my boss and complaining. That's just ridiculous. And then that's,
that's another one where I fit in.
I don't think I've ever been in a corporate scenario,
but it seems like that that's easy to see.
And other people, you know, like where, you know how like a situation where,
yeah, let me late, let my subordinate take lead.
It seems like that could be a solid,
almost obvious answer for people except myself. You know, like I, I don't,
I don't always point that in where, you know,
I'm sure there's like people out there where it's like, oh,
that this will solve probably a lot of your problems.
Just look at it this way and do it and do that, you know, let,
let one of your subordinates like take lead on this stuff.
And I would predict as far as that goes,
that most people would be pretty surprised. Like, Oh yeah, I guess I should.
I should do that. Yeah. You know, at this point. So you're saying that's a,
it's a pretty obvious solution once you hear it. Yeah.
But you're also saying that it's a difficult solution to actually execute
because most people put in the situation, don't remember it. Yeah.
They don't remember the pointed inwards.
Even like literally you could be getting this advice.
Like right now it can be getting this advice, but hey, hey chocolate,
that sounds like good advice.
And then they'll go like back to work and it applies to it for someone else.
You know, it's like you don't realize it like, man, I should do that. You know,
kind of thing. Yeah. That's the trouble with learning flirty.
Less trouble with learning. Cause it's hard to apply it yourself. Yeah.
Once again, it's like Jujitsu. You can watch,
I can show you how to do it and then you can watch me do it and then I can move
your limbs around so that you do it. And then we do a,
a drill where we drilled a move 20 times and then you get into a competition and
the move is there and you don't execute or you don't execute correctly.
Cause you haven't done it enough. You have to do the move.
You've gotta do the Moon, you gotta do the move. Next question.
So I'm watching deadliest catch.
The fishing show weight. Crab crabs, right? Grabbing,
grabbing show. Yeah. Alaskan crabs respect.
So I'm watching deadliest catch and a deckhand wasn't paying attention and let
too many small crabs into the tank.
This is big trouble for the captain.
So the kid admits his mistake and apologizes. Captain, you're fired.
I've watched you screw up for years. What's the message here? Yes sir.
It's the captain that fires sees the mistake and says the captain says you're
fired. Okay, Gotcha. Okay. Okay, so this
is, this is just tells me a couple of things. This tells me a few things.
This tells me a lot of things, right? First of all,
the boss watched the deck hand screw up for years.
[inaudible] my assumption is that he didn't say anything.
You watched someone screw up for years.
How is the deckhand going to improve if he doesn't get counseled on what his
shortfalls are? Okay, so that's one that that could've happened, right?
That's one assumption. Let's make the other assumption.
The other assumption is that the,
the captain did counsel the deck hand and watch him screwed up for years and
told him, you better not do that. You better not do that.
You better not do that. And he's now done it again. And guess what?
He's getting fired.
[inaudible]
so, so that, that's understandable.
So I think the question is implying kind of like,
uh, you know, hey yo, hey boss, this was my fault.
I shouldn't have let that happen. And now the boss can say, oh, well,
since you're taking ownership of that, that's no problem. We'll let it go.
That's doesn't happen. So, so if you have a,
if you have a concept in your brain that you think that when you,
when you take ownership for something that you're immune then from the
punishment of the mistake you've made, that's not true.
That's absolutely not true.
Taking ownership of a mistake does not relieve you of responsibility of that
mistake. In fact, the opposite of true, when you take ownership of a mistake,
you're taking ownership of the mistake and you are raising your hand and saying,
I own the mistake. And if there's punishment to be made it out,
it needs to land on me.
Hmm.
That's what ownership is. Ownership is not a get out of jail free card. Yeah.
You know what? It's my fault. You know, we joke about this is my bust. Hey,
my bust on that one little won't happen again. So now everyone just ignores it.
No, this is a serious violation.
Having the wrong sized crabs is the kind of thing that gets you rolled up by the
fish and game department and all of a sudden you're getting shot down.
It's a serious business.
Hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of thousands of dollars if not more are at
stake here. And this kid isn't doing his job correctly.
So either the boss, the captain had mentored him and was fed up,
which, which it makes him a good boss.
And this was his last warning and he failed his last warning and there you go.
Hey, I've been watching you screw up. I told you, you screwed up.
I've written you up about screwing up.
And I told you not to let this happen again and you just let it happen again.
You're fired.
Or maybe the boss wasn't that squared away and he hadn't counseled him.
He hadn't had the hard conversations early with him to square them away and now,
yeah,
the boss leaves something to be desired because he's just the first defense he's
that he talks to him about is, hey, you're fired.
When I took ownership of the blue on eight extra note in extreme ownership,
first chapter, I could have been fired for that. Yeah, I could have been fired.
My boss could have said, yeah, yeah, you're right. This is your fault.
We can't have that happen out here. You're fired. And I, you know, and I said,
Roger, that it's not, hey, I own this.
Please let me go. Yeah, I took, now here, I will say this though,
if so, so taking extreme ownership is not a get out of jail free card.
But I will tell you this, if you make excuses,
it is going to be worst in 99% of the situations.
Well, you know, the small crabs snuck in when I wasn't looking.
That's not my fault. Tactical crabs on the move. Right?
Then you just look like an idiot. Right.
So then another thing that this brings up is this idea of preemptive ownership.
And that is taking own, if you take ownership of something, you don't,
you don't want to take ownership after the fact.
Extreme ownership,
the idea of extreme ownership in its purest and most effective form isn't,
hey, something went wrong and I'm now taking ownership with a mistake.
That's not the, that's not the best extreme ownership scenario.
The best extreme ownership scenario is when you take ownership prior to the
mistake happening and you realize that if the,
if there is going to be a mistake, you are going to own it.
So what you're gonna do is you're going to work hard to prevent that mistake
from happening. That's preemptive ownership.
You're taking ownership before the mistake happens. So this kid,
this deckhand could have dumped,
put procedures in place to make sure no small crabs got in and sorted them out
properly. But instead he thought, oh, you don't want it to be no big deal.
I'll just take ownership. And then they'll say it's okay or you know,
I'll blame someone else or whatever. His thinking in his brain. If he says,
look, if I let small crabs in here,
I am going to own it and I am going to get fired. Guess what?
Perhaps he would have worked a little harder to prevent these small crabs from
being where they weren't supposed to be. But see,
when you have that out, when you think you can just blame someone else,
you know that allows you to be slack when you think, well,
you know, this isn't really my responsibility.
That's why when I work with companies and they'll have some thing that's going
wrong, some problem, some procedure that's not working correctly,
some timeline that's not being met.
And one of the first questions I ask at it normally like a huge step in the
right direction to re to resolve the problem is I go, okay,
who's in charge of that process?
And a bunch of people will be looking around at each other and no one's raising
their hand. And the minute I see that, I go, hmm, interesting. This is,
this is the answer to me.
Now we know why the process is ineffective because no one has ownership of it
and if no one has ownership of it and the thing doesn't get done when it's
supposed to get done. Everyone just points at each other and says, yeah,
well it wasn't my fault was his fault.
It was their fault and then no one takes ownership of known. Solves it. Yeah.
Whereas if you say, okay, echo, you are in charge of this process.
If it doesn't work, I'm coming after you. You know?
Now you can step up your game preemptively to prevent a mistake from occurring.
Prevent the little crabs from getting in the pot. Yeah,
so taking ownership isn't just get out of jail free card.
If you have a subordinate,
you are actually responsible for counseling them and coaching them and mentoring
them and explaining to them what the standards are so that they can meet the
standards.
Explaining explicitly what the standards are so that they can meet those
standards
and the optimal ownership takes place not only after,
but more importantly before something goes wrong.
There you go.
Not to mention you got to take responsibility for solving the problem. Yes,
you do. Which apparently this deckhand guy has not. Yeah, he didn't take,
he took ownership for the mistake.
He didn't take ownership for the resolving the problem.
He also didn't implement us a solution to the problem.
There's all kinds of problems by the way. Yeah. So there you go. Next question.
What mistakes did you make early discussed in your live podcast that could have
progressed you further? Hmm. Yeah,
I think there's just some real big obvious ones. Wasted a bunch of time.
You know, you wasted a bunch of time when you're young,
you think you got forever and you waste time.
And whether it's doing stuff that's not productive,
whether it's going out,
getting drunk or whatever dumb things you waste time doing, whether it's just,
just wasting time and, and you know what? Look,
I'm not saying don't have fun in your life because that's wrong answer to.
That's too extreme. But what I am saying is I,
I sometimes I had a little too much fun.
Sometimes I wasn't focused on the right thing. So wasted time is number one,
wasted money, wasted a ton of money on dumb stuff.
And I'd say that both of these are wasting time, wasting money.
Those are like the two biggest mistakes that I've made.
But I would say that the root of those mistakes is that I didn't do a good job
of connecting the future to the present. Right.
You just don't when you're young.
I shouldn't say that when I was young because I don't want to put a universal
blanket of being dumb on everyone,
even though you're nodding your head pretty heartily over there because that's
probably, yeah, we see a lot of people do this, right? A lot of us,
we waste our time,
we waste our money and we don't connect what we're doing right now with what's
going to happen in the future and that is not a good policy to have.
What we want to do and what I try and instill with kids, with my kids, with,
with kids that I talk on the podcast because I want to connect what decisions
are being made right now with decisions that with the,
with the end state that you end up with in your future.
So if you take advantage of your time,
you're going to be in a much better place. If you, if you save your money,
you're going to be in a much better place. If you invest your money properly,
you're going to be a much better place. If you train and you treat people,
if you train hard, you're going to be in a much better place.
If you treat people respectfully and you build relationships,
you're going be in a much better place. If you do the opposite of those things,
you're going to be in a worse place. If you treat people like dirt,
you're going to, it'll come back to bite you. If you waste your money,
you won't have it. If you waste your time, you'll run out.
So I think the biggest mistake really for me was that I failed to connect the
present to the future.
The only ways that I succeeded in that early on was through luck.
Like I joined the navy and, and, and I'm very lucky that I did,
cause I was immediately building my future even though I had no idea.
It wasn't my intent. I was immediately,
I bought a house that was a great, what I wanted.
What did I buy it for? I wanted a place to live. What did I end up with?
An incredible investment, uh, enough to buy another house.
That one was a little bit more intentional. Oh, okay. Wait a second.
If I owned another house,
and I was just talking about this with a friend of mine who was like that,
I was explaining when,
and he remembered when I got my second house and I was like,
in my mind, Donald J. Trump,
the real estate landlord like master, right?
Someone was going to be paying me rent, you know, and,
and I had another house that I was going to live in. So that was, uh,
that was what I started making this shift where I connected the present with the
future. Yeah.
So what you do today is directly correlated to where you'll end up in the
future.
That is in echo's favorite sort of thread of this entire podcast is playing the
long war and it took me too long to start fighting the long war.
That's what I'll say that that will say the biggest mistakes from my early
yeah. And really in a way it, I mean it could be,
it could be viewed as not even really mistakes.
I guess this is more of just sort of, that's the way things happen.
Cause B most times we figured these things out later in life be when the long
game starts to materialize. Because when you're early in your career,
the only the short game is sorta there and then in a way,
and actually know at the end of the day, no, because even as a little kid,
you know, the long game, you're familiar with it a little bit.
Cause like you ever had an ear out to save your money for something like a
optimist prize toy, you know, something like that.
And they said you gotta save your money for it and you grow,
you save your money. You know, that's playing the long game.
Yep. As a kid, you know the kid version. So it's kind of the same thing,
but maybe it's not as intuitive. You know, when you're little, when you're big,
when you're grown. [inaudible] difference. It's the other thing,
other weird thing is like someone has to tell you,
but like we just talked about,
sometimes when people tell you you still just don't listen to them. Yeah.
You know, people say, hey, you should really do this. And you go, yeah,
whatever. That's for you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's for you.
One of my,
one of my uncles friends won the lottery years ago,
like in the 70s and he won one of those big lotteries where he got money every
year. You know, you could take the lumps on or you could take the payments,
the payments. He took the payments. Yeah. Well won the lottery. Right.
Literally won the lottery, won the lottery. And so the payments lasted 20 years.
Well, when you're 22 that's, that's forever. Yeah, right.
That's forever. Yeah.
And so my dad was talking to him,
talking to the guy that won the lottery and now he was at like the 19 year mark.
And guess what he had done with all this money, spent it,
and he invested in real estate. Did he buy start companies?
What do you think he did with this money? Spent it. Yeah,
he bought car and whatever that tends to Rosen, you know,
or whatever,
dated girls and went to bars and went out for nice dinners and did that for a
long time. And so my, my dad says, Hey, you know,
they're talking about it. He says, well, you know, my, you know,
this is the last year that I'm getting my monthly payments for winning the
lottery. And my dad says,
what are you gonna what are you going to do when the payments aren't coming in
anymore? And he says, I'm going to win again.
So yeah, that's planning in a sense. We all kind of,
and the, no, it's not tough man. That's one.
But that tends to go like that for lottery winners.
Yeah. Apparently the lottery winning isn't a big like happiness. No,
it's bad. Yeah. Ends up being bad because life is a long,
long game and no matter how you play it,
the long game is the one that shakes out, you know?
So if you're over here playing the short game, that's,
that's why you lose in life. If you play the short game all the time.
And the people who play the long game, they just, all you gotta do is play it.
You don't even have to dominate it. Although I'm not recommending,
not trying to dominate, I'm not saying trying to necessarily have to,
you can come in shoot second to the last place, but if you're playing the game,
you're going to be doing good in the long. When you,
when you come in second to last place in the long game,
you still just beat every single other person that's playing the short game.
You beat them all. Yeah. And it's not,
and they're over there looking around like what happened? Yeah. How is
who you're so squared away. Yeah.
But it's not that complicated, you know? I mean, it's not easy. It's not easy.
You're wired to play the show to go deep on this,
on that last warrior kid podcast. Yeah. Oh yeah. The, this death. Yes.
You had a need to get over the short term gratification. Yeah. And that is the,
one of the biggest lessons a kid can learn is that my actions today will affect
my future. Yeah. And it's hard to convince them of that.
It seems so distant.
Like the future seems so distant when you're young.
I was having another discussion with someone the other day, a parent,
and there was a level of frustration that,
and it's the typical level of frustration from the parent, which was, you know,
the kid has a lot of potential,
but they're like natal not training the way they should be and not working the
way you know all that, all that stuff.
And what I tried to explain to the parent was that the potential that you're
telling your kid that he has,
they do not even comprehend what that means. It is not a,
it is not a, it's not something that they can understand.
It's completely intangible. Like even when you say, Oh,
if you keep practicing this, you could be the champion.
This means you might as well say, if you keep practicing this ebook, Bobby's,
you'd be rubbing off on me. It means nothing to them.
So that's what potential is to a little kid. A little kid doesn't understand it.
Yeah. And so yes, you try and convince them, you try and explain it to them.
But what I recommend is instead of trying to explain to them this massive
concept of what their potential is,
you try and give them some short term rewards that lead them in the right
direction, that are, are supportive of the long game,
but they're easier mental connections for the kid. And this,
the same thing applies to employees as well. Right? You know,
or you get a young young employee that's, you know,
they're not thinking they could be the the regional manager, right.
They're just thinking they're just happy to be here. Yeah, but you're,
you're looking at, I'm calling this, you know, this is sharp kid could be good.
So you might not say, look,
one day you're going to be the regional manager in 22 years. Think about that.
When you, somebody gets hired on as whatever and you say one day you're,
you can be the regional manager and you could make whatever this big chunk of
money they're looking at. You Go, who mode are going to be here? You know,
about Bumblebee, you'd have this job, particular whatever.
So what you want to do is just tie something a little bit closer to them,
to their reality of, hey, here's where you could get,
here's why the bonus program works here. Have you seen this?
You can make an extra whatever. Yeah.
And it's going to move them in the right direction, the long game,
but they can comprehend it immediately. That's my recommendation. Shoot.
Even just compliments and encouragement are good.
Little micro rewards for those short term likes.
Phil [inaudible], my kids, once again, we can't abuse them. Yeah. Can Abuse,
you know, friendliness with our children. We can, we can't abuse that.
Maybe that's not the right word. Right. We can't abuse cheerleading. Yeah,
right. We can abused cheerleading with our kids in everything that they do is
beautiful, right? Yeah. No,
that's this beautiful piece of art that you just created. What is it
beautiful and everyone is no. Yes sir. It's like,
that's not good. Yeah, that's not good.
But you're just talking about abusing. The other thing is the other thing,
you have to be careful with this. You know, you're telling your kid like, well,
you know, you're special or you're,
you're so perfect, you know? Yeah. And so, you know, yeah.
So this can get better. Yeah. I get your marginal
Zest Nova. No, that, yeah. And what I mean, encouragement in, in,
in compliments. It's like if they do something good,
you compliment that good thing. That's essentially it. And yeah,
like anything you can throw out too many and you can throw out too little
really, because the, the, the,
the fulfillment or satisfaction of receiving that compliment isn't big enough
for the work that they just do and be like, man,
I don't want to do those 100 privately.
My daughter do 90 burpees the other day.
Why 90 did you just want to withhold? No, I'm worth a century.
She didn't get to 90 and say, Hey dad, you do whatever you want.
I'm getting 10 more. Watch this. We're going to do a Hundo. Well,
here's the thing, she's done that before, but not with 90.
So I'm working her up and I started from like, I was like, hey,
when she was real as her time, I didn't time it.
How are we going to recognize improvement?
Cause we're going to get to the number first, then we go for time. Got It.
So I mean that's the story. I mean it's not like, you know,
my life's mission of course. It's just the fun little thing that I do.
But if sounds fun, wonderful, sure.
But so if, if I'm like, hey, um, hey, you're super strong.
They liked that. Or my kids like that when you call them strong.
So every time they do something like exercise or something like that and they,
they, they do a good workout or whatever,
I'll say how strong they are or how strong they are looking or being or
whatever.
But if that feeling isn't enough to constitute that super hard,
where like if I over push him like I 90 given where we are with burpees,
with her, um, she's not ready.
She wasn't ready for 90 at this time. Since she did she cry.
She know she didn't cry thankfully cause she'll cry. No shame. She'll cry.
I went for a run with my youngest daughter. This is a while ago.
I don't know how she old, she was at the time, but I was like, okay,
we're going to start running because I wanted to improve her mile time at the
school. I said, okay, you want them prove that mile time I know how to do it.
Here we go.
So her mile time was weak and I said we can
get a better. So the first run we went on, I'm not kidding.
She, by the time we got one minute deep,
she had tears welling up in her eyes. Yeah. And and you know, I said,
hey, just keep going. But the, the, the point of saying,
this is my,
when I try and give children,
especially my children or any children compliments,
I try and compliment their hard work. Yeah.
As opposed to you're strong or you're smart.
What I say is you really worked hard for that and look at this great result.
Because what it makes them realize is that great results come from hard work.
And guess what?
That is the truth because we all know people that were incredibly smart,
incredibly strong, incredibly talented and incredibly gifted,
and they didn't do anything with any of those things because they didn't
understand that they had to work hard. Even if you have all that skill,
if you don't work hard, you're not going to get anywhere. Dang,
that's a good little.
So additional lean towards complementing the hard work and that's what you
really want to see. Let's face it. Let me ask you this,
and this is a tough question.
Would you rather have someone on your team that is extremely talented or
extremely hard worker? You know, of course it's easy. We all want to say,
well I take the talent cause we can make the person work hard,
but that's actually not true. Yes, it seems. And the real talent,
the best talent really is you get someone that just knows how to grind and work
hard, like that's good and that's going to be much more valuable than,
hey, this person's super smart, or hey, this person super strong.
Occasionally you get someone like GSP. Yeah.
George St Pierre who was way talented in multiple modalities and was a hard
worker. You know, that person becomes a world champion. Yeah.
Sometimes you get a world champion that that's just there because of hard work.
Sometimes you get a world champion that's just there because of talent.
Occasionally you get someone that's both and they're usually sort of a stared
more dominant, like a dominant chin. Yeah, that's true. And that's good.
I started to compliment the hard work. Um, I,
I personally like both. I liked the white, especially with my son,
like being strong and stuff. He really likes that, you know? So he'll,
it's to the point where like if you help him do something, he'll get mad at you.
Kind of get mad at. Yeah. Which I kinda like,
I don't know where that's going to lead, you know? But I liked that currently.
Um, so he, he has that sense of pride, you know,
we're being strong is a good thing. I know that's a little,
there's nothing wrong with that. So yeah. But man,
if you add the hard work part of it,
because being strong as this essentially a result, you know,
and he doesn't obviously too, yeah,
it's really going to be easy connection for you to make because it's hey you're
strong and that's because you work hard, you know,
because many of you say you're strong cause you got just, yeah, cool.
I'll just sit over here. [inaudible] what do you got?
Yeah, it's true Ed. And when you,
especially if you don't recognize the hard work part of it, you know,
and you just think you're as a kid, you'd just rolling around and strong.
You're, you're basically, you,
you've reveled in the results for so long where it's now when it's hard work
time, it's kind of like, wait,
I'm not used to that part of this where they say that can happen too.
They call them gazelles in buds. These are people that are like really fast,
good athletes. And, but they never lost before. Yeah. And yes,
they start getting beat down, which you do get beat down and they lose.
They can't handle it mentally. Yeah. Oh yeah. So yes sir. That is, um,
that's real. Next question. Juggle.
My wife told me that she sees I am much more direct and less cordial than I used
to be. I feel I've pushed too much into getting after it
and it makes those around me feel like I've changed to someone else. Yeah.
We have to be really careful, right, Mr.
Because being more direct and less cordial is definitely not getting after it.
In fact, it's the opposite.
If you are getting after it in a correct manner,
your wife should be completely stoked because you're going to have more time for
her cause you're going to be doing time management properly.
You're going to have, you're going to be doing better at work,
which means you're going to be getting promoted or whatever,
getting paid more or you know, getting jobs, stability or whatever,
something like that. You're going to be healthier because you're,
you're working out, you're gonna be stronger cause you're working out,
you're going to be more organized with things
and you're going to be more thoughtful about building.
That's what we're getting after is like your, your relationship.
It should be improving. Yes. Not this, and this is one of those,
this is one of Echo Charles's favorite things to talk about or sexually
something that you've just brought up a bunch of times on the podcast,
which is when someone says no, that's just how I am.
Like I'm just going to tell you the truth cause that's just how I am.
Just making an excuse for being a jerk coming out of the gate,
which is not good. So if that's what you're doing with your wife, you know what,
I'm just gonna get after it. Hey there's tuna casserole sucks.
I'm just telling you what it is. That's how I roll. Like, no,
you're actually rolling in the wrong direction when you're getting after it in a
good way. Your wife will be stoked.
I was getting interviewed the other day and I realized this.
So I've written eight books.
The eighth one comes out in January of 2020 it's a lot of writing.
I wrote 90% of the words in those books while my family was asleep.
Then it made almost no impact on the family.
Hmm. I'm writing these books.
Editing is a little bit different cause there's a timeline on editing.
So sometimes my, my family would be awake while I was editing and it,
I had to get stuff turned back in and it's a pain.
But that's like it takes a week. Right.
But the other 90% of getting after it was done while my family is asleep.
If you contrarily are getting after it at the expense of your family and
friends, that's not, that's actually being selfish.
[inaudible]
so that's one part. Okay.
So maybe you need to check yourself there and make sure that you're got your
priorities in order. The there is a chance, however,
that
your friends don't like seeing you start to get some out to do,
right. You start to be more successful, start to lead a better life.
There's all kinds of groups of people that will just drag you back down.
They don't want to see you win. Yeah. That's sort of, I don't know,
is that the fundamental kind of baseline human instinct?
I don't want to see you win.
If there is an element of it too too, I would not be surprised. Yes.
Put it that way, but I don't,
there's at least a nontrivial part of the proper [inaudible] population that
does not want to see you win. Yeah. There's at least a percentage,
whatever that percentage is of the people that you know that does not want to
see you in, they would rather see you fail. They would rather,
and maybe fails not the word,
but they would at least rather have you stay with them. Yeah. Yeah.
That makes sense. So there's a chance that that's going on.
Is there a chance that that's going on with your wife? Hopefully not.
That's a slim chance because if you think about it, your success,
her success is predicated on your success. I mean, you are bound to each other.
Both. Each of your success is predicated on each other's success.
So do I want my wife to be successful? Oh yeah. Because I,
that's my wife and she's looking at me going, yes, go be successful.
The more successful I am, the more successful she is. So there's a,
there's most likely your, your wife in my opinion,
would be supportive of your efforts unless you're just getting out of control.
There is a chance, I guess that a wife could see, you know,
someone change and you know, that's not the person that I married. Right.
But hold on,
the person that you married was lazy and I'm over here getting after it.
[inaudible] the person that you married was making x amount of money and I'm
making a lot more than that.
The person that you married wasn't in good physical shape.
I'm in good physical shape.
Most of the time the wife would say, cool, yeah, I'm getting a better deal now.
Occasionally I think you would get a,
a, a spouse,
I guess it could be the male or the female could happen on either side that
goes, oh, you want to work hard and I'm going to really not looking to do that.
I was comfortable. I was comfortable. That's it. Yeah. I'm comfortable.
I don't want you getting all crazy.
I'm over here being comfortable so that could happen. I think that's unlikely.
I think what's most likely is you are focused on yourself a little bit too much.
Check yourself for that. That should be the first person you look at you. Yeah,
that's true. Huh? Cause like this is actually kind of common where
husband, wife,
whichever the scenario is where one let's say let's say two people,
they get married whatever years down the road.
One of the people in the couple relationship improves themselves a lot to lose a
bunch of weight there. They're literally by their own standard.
They were not very attractive when they got married,
but now this is 10 years later, whatever.
They become straight up attractive now making more money.
More people want to hang out with them cause they're nicer.
Like all this stuff straight up across the board improvement.
Meanwhile the other person in the relationship didn't do that. Still married,
still all good. No infidelity, nothing like that. Still married.
But that person who didn't improve themselves will feel like they got phased out
or Kinda like, like the person might want to upgrade or something like that,
you know? So it's like, it is a possibility.
They try and drag the person back down. Yeah. Cause you need to be back here.
I need to be, feel secure now I'm this husband and now my wife's high,
I'm not used to hot life because when we got married, you weren't that hot.
I loved you for you and you know all this stuff and you know what they say or
whatever and um, and now you're up late, you know,
I don't know if I'm thinking of Shit cliche movie thing, but anyway, the,
the wife's like all good looking now. People were like,
people at the store like compliment here and all this stuff and the is not used
to it. And now in his mind, a little thing developed sorts. Like, oh,
like I'm not good enough now for this hot,
hot girl and I'm going to buy her some Cheetos. Yeah. Bring her back down.
So like at least have some mad at you. You know,
manageable amount of control person. So that's, you know,
that's not an uncommon thing in that specific scenario.
I guess that scenario is not very common though.
It's not a very common scenario.
And then it would have to be doubly uncommon for someone to actually want to
drag them back down. I have to throw it out there though.
Cause it is a possibility. Yeah. But for this particular question,
I don't think so. Only because this little indicator right here,
my wife told me that she sees I am much more direct and usually much more direct
means insensitive in my experience. Wives don't do good.
Generally speaking, within sensitivity, less cordial.
That's another one in my opinion, in my experience, cause I'm married. Yeah,
cordial. You learn things. Yeah. I'm going to give you an example.
Something I learned about my wife, if my,
if my wife, if it isn't on the, it's
about enough to make my wife get mad. Right. So in other words, if I said,
hey, I'm going away for one month, a month from now,
I'm going away for six months on a work trip.
I'll be back when I'm done with those six months and when I'm gone and you're
not able to hear from me at all. She'd be like, okay, got it.
When do you leave? And I'd say, well, I'm leaving. Whatever. Yeah,
September 1st and she'd go, okay,
she wouldn't be even remotely upset. She'd be good to go. Yeah.
If it was Friday night and I came home and said,
oh, I'm, I didn't tell you Saturday. I said, I didn't tell you,
but I'm going over to echos to watch the UFC.
There's a decent chance that she's mad about that because she had in her mind
that we were going to eat whatever we were going out for dinner or whatever,
but I didn't, I didn't give the preplanned. Yeah. Situation.
What if she didn't make a plan for that? It was just sort of,
maybe we could do that. It's, it's, no, it's not on her.
It's on me. It's on me for not informing her. Of what was going on,
cause it doesn't really matter.
All she knew is that I was coming home and I was going to be around and that was
what was happening because anything that is not, you know what's really funny,
this is again with my wife and this is, this is where it became evident to me.
Even if it's something that is positive for my wife,
if I don't give her pre planning cycle on, on what's gonna happen.
So in other words,
if I was flying home and I'd been gone for a week and I s you know,
got home and busted through the door and said, hey, I,
I'm on a tail end of a 72 hour fast, I'm starving,
I'm taking you out and I made reservations for this really nice dinner,
I'm going to go get some, you know, a $200 steak right now,
some steak, there's a chance
that the percentage should be 100% she stoked, right?
That should be the percentage. However, with my wife,
there's a a 20 to 30% chance that she says,
you know, I was gonna take, you know, I was going to take our daughter to,
you know, uh, the raffle. I don't know,
to play Bingo and like that is enough. And, and I,
what I don't do is I say, oh cool, you know what? We'll go tomorrow.
What I don't do is try and impose it.
So what you're saying is like lack of being cordial.
What I'm saying is that's not just like,
that's one example of me not being cordial. So I don't,
I try not to, I guess. I guess, I guess to sum it up,
my wife doesn't really like surprises, right? She likes to have a plan.
She to know what's happening and then she'll execute the plan.
So that's what you gotta be careful of you. What you gotta be, well not,
not what you gotta be careful of.
That is one example of how these little things, they don't make sense.
It doesn't make sense that some,
that my wife wouldn't be super stoked to go out to a awesome steak house.
That doesn't make sense to anyone. Well, you know,
then that's a superficial thing and let me tell you something else that makes it
a little bit tricky is I'm super insensitive to like changing plans.
Like people change plans with me. I'm like, whatever. It's no fun.
It's literally no factor. Like, Oh we, oh yeah,
we've been planning to do this for six months. Someone's like, oh,
I can't do it. I'm like, okay, cool. Yeah. You know what I mean?
Like it means nothing to me. When things change, it means nothing.
It has no impact on me. I have no emotional reaction to someone saying,
hey this, we can't do this now. And I'm like, okay, cool.
I'm going to do something else. Yeah. So I'm at the other end of the spectrum,
which means it took me a little while to figure out that, oh,
this makes you mad. Got It. Cheer
problem. And probably something like one level, like under the surface too.
It's not like, Hey, I had this good, you know, the raffle was,
was planned in my head in that raffle is important. The raffle is not important.
Neither is the dinner. It's like that part of it on that level is not important.
It's one level deeper. It's the fact that I had the soup, my head,
you didn't tell me this other thing.
And now like what I had in my head really means nothing. So it's kind of that.
Here's another other
funny thing about my wife
is she's so into the planning thing that if I plan something,
it has way more value to her. So in other words, if I say,
hey, when I get back this Friday,
I'm going to do a fast and I'm going to be super hungry.
I'm going to make reservations for this Friday, right?
And we can go out and get an awesome steak Tomahawk Ribeye.
And like the fact that it was preplanned.
Like I've done this before where I've taken her in and I've gotten reservations
and she'll be like, did you make reservations? And I'll say, yes, I,
I'll be like, yeah, I did. And I can see like a little smile.
Like I care a little bit more that I made those reservations. Like that's what,
what the spontaneity thing. No, no, no,
no points for spontaneity, zero, zero points responding.
It only points for preplanned fires, you know y,
y cause it's thoughtful. Yeah. I exactly, yes, yes. Yeah. That's great.
That's good. That's good. That's an interesting quality right there.
And I guess my point in saying this, this,
these things is that everyone has these little personality traits.
People you work with, people, your, your spouse, your children,
they have these things. And if you figure out what those things are,
you can actually utilize them to your advantage and you can bypass things that
will be problematic. And something that you've said too is you say, oh,
you do this stuff to me. Meaning Jocko does you,
I do some like leadership trick to you and you know that I'm doing it,
but it still like it works and it still makes you feel the way that you know
it's supposed to make you feel.
But that's my point where like my wife will listen to this. Yeah. And it's,
and then I'll make reservations and she'll still be happy.
Even though that she knows that I'm doing it just because I know that it's going
to be something that makes her happy. Yeah, so just because you reveal like,
hey, I know this is what you're like,
or even whether you reveal it or not doesn't matter.
When someone has that characteristic,
then you can utilize that characteristic and I know that's not the best sounding
word to talk about like manipulating my wife's emotions,
but what I want to do is manipulate her emotions to make her feel happy about
something. The right, not necessarily a bad thing. It's a good thing.
So be cognizant when you're dealing with other human beings.
Look for these things. You see these things. If you take a step back,
if you don't take a step back, you'll never see them. If you can't detach,
when you tell your wife something and you you,
you see that it makes her mad if you can't detach.
If you talking to an employee and you see that they're getting frustrated and
you can't detach to try and figure out what that is,
you will not going to make any real progress.
So yeah, that's been direct thing.
We like to be direct or when people are direct to us,
it makes things easier for us, you know, but doesn't as we wait, who's the,
we were talking to whoever people who, because here's the deal, man.
Direct is a very, uh,
a very blunt force tool and not many people wield it well,
and not many people receive it well. Yeah.
So if you're one of these people is that you're all just look to be direct,
right? That's not good. And very seldom
do you end up in situations where you can just be direct with people.
You have to have real strong built relationships with people where you can just
be that blunt and direct with them.
Now there are methodologies where you can be direct without being direct.
You know, you can say things that are, hey,
this is what we need to get done right now. You can take an edge off of it.
You can end with the way you usually do that is by taking ownership of what it
is you're trying to make happen. So what I don't say is like Echo,
you need to get this thing edited tonight. Yeah. Great. I don't do that.
I might say, hey is there any chance we could get this thing edited tonight?
Cause if we don't, we're going to have a gap in releases,
which by the way we haven't had, and that's kind of a thing. Yeah.
Yes. Even you just kind of know that it's a thing. It is, isn't it? Right.
And all of a sudden you want to edit that thing,
not because I told you to boot cause you want to keep the gaps from opening up.
Sure. So I was, I was directly telling you but I was indirect. Yeah.
So there's ways to do it,
but you gotta be careful with direct direct me.
It takes a long time to,
to hone the scalpel of direct to where it just gets,
where you want it to cut. And it doesn't leave any collateral damage.
Not many people are good at it. Very few people are good at it.
Sorry. Next question Jocko.
And you know, that makes people mad. What does the,
when you say, listen, you can't just be, you can't just,
you can't just throw to people. PR People want to say like, there's a book,
there's a book called radical
frankness or something like that. That's not the name of the book,
but it's something like that. It's like, hey,
we just going to tell the total radical transparency or something like that.
And it's like, well, we're just going to tell the truth all the time and we,
we can get there, but man, it is work. Yeah.
And it's not even work that has to be that,
that necessarily
is the best use of work, you know?
So yeah. I just know, I just know, I hear people all the time, well, you know,
and people, that's what people want me to say. I'll go and work with a company,
look, you know what, we really need help. Let's,
we just need to really learn to be direct with each other. Yeah.
And what they really should be saying is what we need to do is we need to learn
to communicate with each other,
be open about what issues we have, how to solve those problems,
and be more tactful in, in our discussions so that people are receptive.
Yeah. Cause think about what I just said.
If it's not just about me being direct,
the more important,
the only way that I can be direct is if I have set you up in such a way that you
or I've built you in such a way that you're receptive to my directness because
me being direct without you being receptive, it doesn't work.
And so often that's what I see. I see. Hey, I'm direct, but,
but you're not receptive. It's, it's game over, you know?
So even if I'm direct,
I'm only 50% of the solution because you have to be receptive. Yeah.
What's easier? When I, when I go indirect,
I become 90% of the solution because I'm going to get it into your brain without
resistance. Yeah. So I, it's an easier, it's easier up front as me.
I'll just be direct. Yeah. That's easy upfront cause I'd just say Echo,
you need to get this stuff edited now direct that's direct.
What are the chances of you being receptive to that? 50% yeah. You know,
whereas if I, well let me rephrase that. In order for this to be effective,
you have to be receptive to it.
So I only have 50% of the solution.
You have the other 50% whereas if I say, like I said before, you know,
hey echo, we is there any chance we could get this done tonight?
Cause here's what's at stake in it. And I go indirect and I make that idea.
I'd make your answer. You're going to give me the answer I want.
I mean I know it can be edited tonight. Right. I know. That makes sense.
And so I'm going to,
you're actually going to tell me you I'm putting it into,
I'm giving you,
all you have to do is just tell me and now I'm the one that's receptive. Yes,
we can't. Oh that's great. That's great. I'm glad.
So that's something very important to talk about.
If you want to talk about learning to be direct with each other,
what you really have to learn is how to be receptive to directness. That's the,
that's the long pole in the tent. That's what organizations are missing out on.
Being direct as easy. Yeah. Being direct is the easiest thing in the world.
You're tell people what you think. That's easy. Yeah.
What's hard is setting the other person up,
developing relationships so that they're receptive to what you're saying. Yeah.
Be careful. You play football back in the day and
[inaudible] this new quarterback came in a few. What's weird is,
I forget his name. I'm just drawing a blank right now, but new young guy,
tall 10 he had a gun. If you're a quarterback and you have a gun,
that's impressive. You know for sure it means you throw far and fast.
Here's the thing though, especially when you're new, you know,
and you have a gun, you're, you're going to show that gun.
You know you're going to be like when you're playing, you know,
when you're warming up before practice and stuff like that,
you're throwing at it and they're throwing it hard.
So this guy was throwing it hard at me as receiver and we're just stay.
He was just standing and we were just standing there. I wasn't running routes.
So he's throwing it and it's hurting my hand to the point where I couldn't catch
some of them because they were coming just too fast for, you know,
for that distance or whatever.
And he sure I was impressed with this guy's gun,
but he, when we'd want run routes and stuff, he'd still kind of do that.
I guess maybe to impress the coaches, you know, he's a young guy or whatever.
Um, and here's the thing, like people would miss his balls.
They wouldn't catch him because they're coming too hard.
They're hurting your hands, they're messing you up, you know?
So it makes it really hard. I get it. It's great practice for the receivers.
Totally is.
But as far as to effectively land a a pass, you know,
to complete a pass probably doesn't work like that.
And we had this other f Chordal Gone Echo. Let me just stop you.
Cause you may have just made like the best analogy you've ever made on this
podcast. That is it cool if that, if you can throw that thing direct,
but if you're throwing it too hard and the person's not ready to receive it,
right or not even, not even to mention that you might not be ready to read,
you might be looking in the other direction that's going to hit you in the back
of the head. What good is that direct comment? It's zero. Good. It's not good.
Hurting your hands when you've tried to receive it. It hurts you. Yeah.
And you don't want to hear anymore.
You don't want it any more to be thrown at you. Nope. Okay. Proceed.
As opposed to this other quarterback who came in from Stanford by the,
your hard work is paying off. Thanks.
So this other quarterback came to that quarterback. Make it anywhere.
Did he make it be NFL? He did not make it to the NFL. So,
so quarterback came in, his name is Tim Carey came from like Stanford I think.
And he came in, he was the kind of the opposite, actually not the opposite,
cause he had a guy he could throw far and stuff or,
but the way he threw it was like, he was like the perfect pass.
Like every distance had a different velocity on it, you know,
it was like that kind of where the next, if he would modulated,
there's so well he modulated so well where like the volume for those chasses
correctness oil, everything. And for them to get better,
he would have to physically walk in and put it in your hand.
It was like that good when he'd come, you know, um,
and when you have them side by side, Oh man, I want that direct guy.
I want the finesse guy, you know. But he did have the capability, um,
to the NFL. Um, I maybe f I forget,
he left Stanford to come to your college. Um, I forget why,
but I think we're good. It was a whole thing.
There was a few Stanford guys that came. Yeah. That's interesting. Yeah.
A few guys from Stanford fruit. Ben came to your school. Uhh, yeah,
he was doing it. I want to say when we changed coaching staffs, Oh,
there might've been some scouts connections,
maybe like some relationships that were already there.
Even some of the coaches I think came from that area. I Dunno,
I forget that was a long time ago. But nonetheless, yeah,
that's the way it shook out. So there you go.
Jocko 13 year street cop here.
My old man died when I was 10 it cut deep and I grew up with no one having two
boys on my own now and loving to get after it on the street.
I worry about the risk.
How do I balance being the spear with ensuring I stay around for them?
So first of all,
we have to recognize that there's no way that you can ensure that you stay
around it. In fact, one day you will not be around one day.
None of us will be around. That's
the fact. And that actually doesn't matter what your job is.
And there's all kinds of things regardless of your job,
whether you have a car accident with you have a heart attack,
whether you have cancer or a plane crash or random violence or some random
accident, there's all different kinds of ways to die.
Now you are correct that the,
the death rate of cops is higher.
Okay?
It's higher than a normal civilian.
But what w like loggers, construction workers,
they all have a higher rates of death than a cop.
Roofers,
okay.
Roofer, if you're a Roofer, you have a higher rate of death than a cop.
Any drivers, anyone that drives for a living,
whether they're a trucker or whether they're literally a traveling salesman,
they have a higher rate of death than being being police.
So no matter what you do,
there's a chance that you could, that you could die.
And I'll tell you what I think about this sometimes in the reverse of like what
do you, what do, what scares you about what your kids do?
If your kids are engaging in activity that could be dangerous,
whether it's parachuting, whether it's rock climbing, whatever.
Like there's things that your kids could do that they could die.
And what you could do is not allow them to do it,
wrap them in bubble bubble wrap and not allow them to go anywhere.
And guess what, even if you do that, there's still a chance
and you've taken away, you know, their growth.
So you can look at it in the reverse as well,
that there's some things that you're not gonna be able to control.
And no matter what you know, your kid could, you could say,
I don't want my kid to join the military.
And so they go to college and what happens in college,
they get hit by a drunk driver. They like,
there's enough bad things that can happen in either one of those situations.
And same thing with you and your job.
You could go get a job doing something unless you get a job that's just straight
up, uh, you know,
in an administrative situation with note,
with very limited commute and very limited driving,
then that might increase your chances a little bit. But then you, you know,
then are you doing something that you actually like to do?
Okay,
so there's your, your dilemma. So what do you do in a situation like this?
What you do is you train and you prepare and you vigilant and you take care of
your sons obviously,
and you would explain your job to them and you explain to them why you train
hard and explained to them why you're willing to make a sacrifice to keep others
safe, including them. You, you work every day to keep them safe as well.
And if you explain that to your sons,
they will grow up with an understanding of service and discipline and duty and
courage and honor.
And by the way, if something did happen to you,
the model that you set for them would have massive impact,
would have massive impact
on them and how they would live their lives.
And I believe it would be actually a positive impact. Sure. Would they miss you?
Absolutely. Sure.
W W would they wish more than anything that you could be back? Yes.
But would they recognize that their dad made this sacrifice?
Yes, they would. Would they live to honor that sacrifice? Yes they would.
So
that's one thing you can do if you want to keep that profession now,
if that, if you can't get around that, if that doesn't make sense,
which it's understandable if you look at me and say, Hey Jocko, I get it.
I want my kids to be raised with honor,
but I'd want to be there and that's more important to me. And if that's where,
if that's where you end up,
then what you have to do is plot out what another job,
what another career is going to be. And like I said,
then you have to make it doing something that legitimately gets you into a
better, a better survival rate.
Which by the way, outlaws just about every outdoor job you could have. So your,
you know, you working construction. Nope. That's not it. Working as electrician.
Nope. That's not working as a lineman. Nope, that's not it. All those jobs,
all those outdoor jobs, go look at this.
Statistics go Google death rates in jobs and there's all kinds of fishermen.
No, forget about it. You know,
there's so many jobs that have a high death rate where accidents happen.
So what you're talking about going into the life you're going into would be
going into, would be an administrative job of some kind. And,
and if you think you can do that or you think that'll be,
give you the satisfaction that you want, then then it's a possibility.
Think about it. But if you look at it and you think, you know what,
that's not for me. Then train hard. Prepare,
build a great relationship with your sons. Stay vigilant.
Don't get complacent ever. And be aggressive.
I have to throw that one in there because in my opinion,
when
when an individual gets scared or gets hesitant or gets over protective of
themselves, I believe they're in more danger, not less danger and more danger.
So if you think that having kids,
having your sons is making you less aggressive and more scared,
I think you're at higher risk.
So if you're going to do the job, you do the job,
you get aggressive when you do the job any. And if you can't,
then you got you.
You might want to look and see if there's other alternatives that are out there.
The other thing I would say is this, how, how often, like you're a street cop,
you've been there for 13 years. Is there another department you could go to?
Is there some other way to serve and, and stay connected?
Use your experience in another, in another way,
maybe one area that has a little less, uh,
probability of getting killed.
Okay.
Again, you got to look if that's something you'd really want to do.
So ultimately, and I tell this to people a lot,
is there's only one person that can make this decision. And it's not me,
the only person that can make this decision. As you.
So think through it before you can even talk about it with your boys,
depending on how old they are. But you can talk about it with them,
explained to them and you know, see what they say.
Um, you know, obviously there's a one way that conversation go, hey,
would you guys be sitting w w would you guys want me to die? Right? Of course.
What are they going to say? Oh my gosh, quit that job immediately.
We don't want you to do that. Right? So you going to have to think about,
I don't know what the ages of your kids are,
but you're gonna have to think through that one whether how you address it with
them. But certainly, um,
I always look at it that there's risk in everything you do.
You might as well take risk doing something that you love doing and that you
know, is helping other people and, you know,
setting a good example for your boys.
And if that doesn't make sense, cool. Find enough, find a different job.
A question.
I was a young boy living in a foster home and was sexually assaulted by my
foster father and sometimes other people over a course of a couple of years,
I was eventually adopted. And what had happened to me.
It was never discussed and I never got help for it.
I was afraid of everything and eventually I played sports in high school and
felt less afraid, went into the army and felt completely unafraid of anything.
When it got out, I got into a long term relationship.
I told my then girlfriend what had happened to me.
She was the first person I ever told about this.
She convinced me to reach out to my foster parents and I did and it was a total
disaster.
They kept my room where all this bad stuff had happened exactly the same as it
was 20 years ago or 20 years prior when these whores had occurred,
I had my moment to confront this monster that had done this to me and I failed.
I used a that he always said to me,
which was w I used a word that he always said to me when he was assaulting me.
He just said, sometimes people change.
All of a sudden I was a week young boy going in and I couldn't fight back.
I left the house and had serious self-doubt.
Eventually I became a cop and then a detective and a faced all types of bad
people from junkies to murders.
I even get full confessions out of child rapists.
I'm sick to my stomach afterwards. It's terrible.
Terrible to hear what these animals do. My question is this,
recently the past has come back with a vengeance.
I can't get through a short time,
maybe an hour or two without thinking about the past and my failure,
the only time I have peace is when I absolutely destroyed myself working out.
I consider it punishing myself and feel better when I do it.
How can I stop this or at least manage it better?
So this is, I mean,
obviously horrible situation and you know, um,
horrible that you had to live through this and that. Any kid or any one,
any human would have to go through this
as far as how you can manage this better.
Um, I'm gonna go a little bit here.
So one of the blocks of training that we go through in a seal platoon is called
close quarters combat. And this is the training.
You're in a thing called the kill house. It's ballistic walls,
there's targets in there. You're moving around dynamically.
You're shooting live fire ammunition, there's people six inches away from you.
You're taking really close shots.
There's a lot of pressure in there. There's a lot of details,
a lot of standard operating procedures and safety procedures that you have to
follow. There's a lot of process. The psyche, do you need to go left or right?
Is that a good guy or a bad guy because you have to identify the targets.
Should you move or should you stay?
How do you communicate that you need to move,
should you shoot or should you not shoot at a target?
And so there's all these things going on. When you enter a room,
all these things that you have to go through,
all these steps that you have to take,
all these procedures that you have to follow,
all these decisions that you have to make and it all happens in a split second.
And so in a kill house,
the training cadre is actually above you. Above the,
it's not a normal house. The, the,
the rooms have what we call catwalks above them.
So the cadre can be up above you in the catwalks and they're walking around and
they're watching you very closely.
It's like watching a football game on TV.
You're seeing it from like the perfect view above the person and they're in the
room with you,
but they're not in your way at all because they're up on the catwalk.
So what happens is when a room entry happens,
there's a lot of,
you catch a lot of critique from the people in the catwalk
and they'll say, you know, you could have,
you could have done this or you could done that, or you could,
you could move left or you should have pushed forward or there's you don't, you,
it would have been better if you'd done this other thing, this.
So there's all these different things. And when my cadre was running it,
you know, that's what we do. That's what happened to me when I was cadre.
That's what I would do. That's what everyone does.
And at some point I kind of realized that all that stuff is good and I get it.
Like you got to get people to run the procedures correctly,
but in a certain point
[inaudible]
no. What I would tell guy, like after a guy was kind of beat down,
like he just couldn't get something right or he would upload a bunch of people
would jump on him about, um,
decision that he made or a movement that he made or whatever.
And I'm not talking about a safety thing cause the safety thing is,
is different.
I'm talking about a tactical decision and when you walk into a room,
there's a bunch of tactical decisions you can make. And, and if there's 10,
if there's five different decisions that you could make when you walk into a
room, there's something that there's, you know,
there's one way of doing it that would be like really clean.
One would be a little bit less, one might be just as clean as the first one,
but it's a different attitude. There's this,
all these different decisions that you could make, you know,
it's like,
okay,
just a multitude of ways that you could react cause that's what this question
is. How you reacted in this situation.
And eventually as I would see this with an individual,
I would eventually [inaudible]
okay.
I, what I would tell guys is listen,
okay,
you did what you did.
Cool.
You did what you did. That's what you did.
That's the decision that you made at the time. And you know what?
There's different ways you could've done it. You don't like the way you did it.
I don't like the way you did it.
[inaudible]
someone at one of the other cadre members doesn't like the way you did it.
It doesn't what I'm saying, it doesn't really matter for, first of all,
you can't take it back to you. You can't go back and undo it. And by the way,
you don't get to rehearse these things to a point where you get to do this
perfectly because you won't be able to do that.
If you rehearsed a move in a room that you had seen before and you rehearsed it
10 times, that's not, that's a totally different game, right?
If I already know what the room consists of and I'm going to rehearse and
choreograph the entire movement, that's a different game.
That's not decision making. That's just, that's just rote memorization.
We're not talking about that.
We're talking about how did you react and what you did is what you did and you
did it for a reason. What you saw in front of you,
you made this decision for a reason. Maybe like, you know,
you saw a threat when there wasn't one there or you lost situational awareness
or you rushed, you went too fast,
you've tried to rush and all those things can kind of can kind of trip you up.
But that's what you did and you did what you did and you can't take it back.
So instead of everyone sitting there saying,
you should've done this and you should have done that, let's do this.
Let's see what we can learn from it.
Let's see why you did what you did.
Let's see why you made that decision.
Because once we know why you did something,
now we have something that we can work with.
We have something that we can improve upon.
Okay.
That is what I think you need to do in this situation.
And really when anyone makes a mistake or has a reaction that they don't like,
you can't worry.
You can't continue to worry about something that has already transpired.
What you have to do is you have to look at it and say,
what can I learn from it?
What can I take from this and and how can I take this mistake and make me
better? So you could look at this, why did you do that?
Right? Maybe you did it because you didn't want to open up these old wounds.
Maybe you did it because you would have you confronting this individual would
cause more drama and that more that drama you re you at that moment you assessed
and said, you know what, this drama isn't worth it.
Maybe you protected yourself from more drama.
And that was your instinct.
And maybe if you were to started confronting this guy and going crazy that you
know,
who knows what could have happened and maybe it could have taken a turn for the
worst. We don't know what the outcome was.
We know that you weren't happy with your decision. Understandable.
But we don't even know what the other decisions would've led to.
So where you're actually getting bogged down and, and,
and distraught about something that you don't even know if it was a good
decision or a bad decision. It feels like it was a bad decision.
But you don't know what the outcomes of the other decisions even were.
So you can't change the outcome of what happened in the past.
You can't do it.
But what you can do is you can grow from it. That's what you can do.
You can learn from it.
You can actually take that scenario and you can mentally replay it in your head
and you can figure out if possibly there would have been or could have been a
better outcome.
Or maybe that that outcome that you had wasn't that bad or maybe it leads
somewhere else. We don't know yet.
[inaudible]
but that's, that's where you are at right now.
You can't change the outcome of something that has occurred in the past.
Now I'm going to,
I'm going to throw a little dichotomy at you right now and I'm going to say
something that's a little bit,
might be a little bit hard to understand.
I'm gonna try and talk my way through it because while you can't,
okay,
change the past,
what you can change is you can absolutely change the way that the past is
perceived.
So let me give you an a detached example. Just another example.
If you had an individual, someone gets fired from a job,
they get fired from their job and when they get fired from the job it,
what it does is it their,
their confidence goes down and they get depressed and they decide they're not
going to even apply for new job because I don't even know if I deserve it.
Get a new job. And they sit around and eventually they,
they go out and apply for kind of like a lesser job.
Yeah.
And you know, who knows,
maybe they start drinking to relieve some of their depression and now they're
late and now they, they end up on a downward spiral.
We would look at them being fired as something that destroyed them and ruin
their life. That's how we would perceive it. Hey, the individual got there.
They were, they weren't doing fine.
Then they got fired and now they lost their confidence. They got depressed,
they started drinking,
they didn't apply for good jobs and now their life is totally different and it's
a bad place.
We would perceive that them getting fired did that to them.
[inaudible]
but if the s if that person,
if a person got fired from their job at any instead it was like a wakeup call
for them
and they immediately applied for a bunch of other jobs and maybe they didn't get
those because they'd just been fired, but maybe they took a lesser job,
a lower paying job.
But they got in there and they had realized they'd made a mistake and they
started getting after that. Like they'd never gotten after it before.
They started working as hard as they possibly could and got promoted and then
got promoted again and just dominated in those positions and went even harder
and dominated even more and eventually took over the whole company.
And this isn't crazy, this isn't too far fetched. This can happen. But if,
if that happened, that same incident,
the firing of this individual would be perceived in a totally different way.
It would be perceived as a catalyst that changed their life for the better.
And there are all kinds of examples like that in the world.
The past
can't be changed.
Okay.
But the past can change you for the better or it can change you for the worst.
And my question is, why not make it for the better?
Why not make the past change you for the better? You hear the term,
you heard the term narrative thrown around these days,
especially like in political circles,
you'll hear it on the news that narratives they're created in the political
arena.
And what the narrative does is it supports an overarching
aim or an overarching value or an overarching goal.
That's what, that's what,
that's the way people use the term narrative right now.
But I'm not talking about that type of political narrative.
What I'm saying here is that you actually write the narrative of what happened
in your past.
I'm not talking about a fabrication of it, I'm talking you get the right,
the narrative of where it takes you. You get to write the narrative,
you get to write the reality of where you end up.
Okay?
You get to write it,
you get to control it,
Huh?
So what I'm saying is [inaudible]
okay,
control it.
Get control of that narrative.
Take control of that narrative that Si,
that horrible story in your past ends the way that you want it to end.
You control the narrative. You control that story.
So make that story good,
Huh?
Make that story epic.
Make that story and make the direction that your life goes.
Make it at relic.
And that's how I think you can get control or may be handled better.
Some of that horrific stuff
that you've been through.
And I think that's all I've got for tonight.
So Echo Charles',
speaking of being heroic. Yes.
Speaking of controlling our own narrative of the past,
of the present of the future, what can we do to
write that heroic story for ourselves? Yes.
Well let's start with the path.
I'm gonna stay on the path we're going to get on the path.
We're going to be on the path. So for the path is Jujitsu, of course,
like we've said many times you're gonna need to get what you get.
I got interviewed the other day
and the guy kind of sets up this kind of big question. Sure.
He says, you know, in this day and age and I'm not going to do him justice.
He was a great question. It was a nice question. I get it. Yeah. And I'm not,
I'm not gonna do it as eloquently as he did it.
But the real question was about, you know,
in this day and age when men,
and it was one of those like men like type things this day and age when men are,
you know,
can be isolated and can get depressed and don't have meaning and all this stuff.
Right. What, what do you know, what do you recommend to men that feel that way,
that feel isolated and feel alone and feel depressed and feel like they don't
have meaning in their life and feel like they can't connect with anyone.
And I was like, oh cool. Yeah, go to Jujitsu classes.
And I felt bad because they wanted me to give like the big found thing about
where to find meaning in your life. And what I said was, yeah,
start training Jujitsu. Cause cause the thing that he grabbed me with is like,
oh, you know, you want you, you want to have a goal, you want to have meaning.
You want to connect with people. You don't want to be alone,
loneliness and all this stuff. I'm like, yeah, yeah, go train Jujitsu.
All of those problems get solved right there dude. Right.
All of a sudden you got people to hang out with. You've got a mission,
you got fitness going on, you got meaning.
There's all kinds of good stuff going on. Yeah.
So go train some Jujitsu is what I'm saying. Yeah. Good place to start.
That's one of those deals too with them.
Like you leave Jujitsu with something,
not just fitness and better health and stuff. You leave with like a skill.
It just feeds into your whole soul. Especially man, manliness thing.
All Man, the capability to defeat another man. Yeah.
We'll have to see.
We'll check in with some of our females because when I talked to our female
Jujitsu practitioners,
they might even feel a little bit better cause they get to like choke men,
no doubt about it. So, yeah. Yeah. So,
so what you were saying basically is try training some Jujitsu look.
Is it a cure all? Yeah. Kind of, yeah, a little bit. Yeah.
If you're a certain people in certain situations, I think, yeah, I think so.
I have a feeling when I leave Jujitsu after I get done training that I feel
good. Yes sir. Just think about that. Just think about,
think if I gave you a pill that said, oh, if you just take this pill,
you'll feel good. You just, you'll just roundly, you'll just feel good. Yeah,
but there's no, in fact,
the only side effects are that you'll be a little healthier and you'll have a,
you'll have a quality skill that you can utilize in the real world.
Just take this pill. Would you take the pill? Who wouldn't? Sure.
What I'm saying is you get to go to Jujitsu. Yeah.
Is it harder than taking a pill? Sure.
But is it harder to eat a steak or eat a pill? Steak? Technically,
technically it's an order to eat a steak. Which one would you rather do?
Eat a stick.
I'd rather eat a steak and I'd rather change a Jitsu than take a pill. Me Too.
So get on that train.
The jujitsu train kid Honda did use to train and you're going to do gen No-gi,
so what kind of gear you get?
You get the best ski question and I realized I liked dramatically interrupting
you. Sometimes I dig into some things.
So the g origin? Yes.
Origin main.com this is where you can get your g many different options.
They come out with new ones is pretty cool.
Pete's very creative with that stuff. Yeah.
I encouraged Pete to continue that creativity and keep it on that level as well.
Anyway, go on. Encourage him. No, I don't.
I encourage all encourage and a compliment as well. So yes,
origin maine.com you can get your g, you can get a rash guard too if you want.
Also some shirts on there, some joggers and whatnot.
Supplements as well. What about just for,
what if you were going to go see a movie, can you wear your g to a movie? Oh,
well no. Okay.
Can you wear your g to a dinner date with your wife? No.
No you can't. So what do we do with the origin then go right? Yes.
Well the good news is we got some American denim,
we got genes. Genes. Yup. Origin genes. Boom. Yeah, those are good man. Those,
those came out really, really good. I think those are going to go go places.
Yeah.
This one I will give Pete some leeway for his creativity because he did this
thing with the yolk of the jeans. You don't have the focus now,
the little piece of,
it's like right below the waistband and there's two types of different yolks.
You can have reverse yoke or, or regular yolk, I guess it's called. Anyways,
it's, it makes it so that the pants fit a certain way.
And then he lined up the tops of the pockets with the reverse yolk,
which means that they're slanted a little bit like the old school Vietnam, uh,
pockets. Okay. So anyways, that's cool.
They're legit. Yeah, they're, they're just like a little bit, you know what?
I was like gathering tails going on, gathering that.
You're starting to appreciate pizza fashion sense. That's what I'm gathering.
You're crazy. I'm saying occasionally. No, no, no, no. Cause here's the deal.
The pockets, because they're at a little angle there.
They're easier to get your hand in and out of which what I'm saying is there is
a functionality because if it didn't, if it wasn't functional,
I wouldn't be talking about it right now. No,
because we don't talk about things like that, but they look dope.
It's what I'm saying.
I think you're starting to appreciate that on I'm saying is I think,
I think Pete did it not for functionality.
I think Pete did it because it looked cool and then I commend his creativity
because not because it looked cool,
but because it provides a level of functionality that does not previously exist
in jeans anywhere. Boom. So I agree with you.
I agree with the whole deal. The whole Gig and man. Yeah. Cha Yeah,
those are good American denim by the way. All made in America. Yes.
Cotton is made in America grown. What about the, uh,
things that you put you fastened the um, with your waist. With the button? Yeah,
the button word Compton.
Just look at a picture of the buttons.
That's enough to be like all sold to begin with. They're pretty dope.
They're very dope actually.
Plus we've got supplements as you were just about to say. Yeah. Supplements.
Important supplements. Not this mega mass. Fuck.
What was that one for the old school [inaudible] number nonetheless.
It's not like that.
Well I guess Kinda Cause Moke is additional print weight cleaner,
clean protein, slow release. Braden did a really good, um,
but let's face it. It just tastes good. Yes, it tastes good.
That might be, what's that word?
That might be the number one priority or the number one benefit.
The fact that it's the best protein you can actually get is awesome too. Yeah.
Cool. Well, you can eat a steak if you want protein as well. So there's,
there's various, you can always eat a steak. That's the problem.
Sometimes you're like on the go. Sometimes you got to get,
sometimes it's you got work to do. You have time to eat a steak.
Sometimes you just want a dessert too. Let's face it. Come on Bro.
Let's face it. So boom, fully facing it. There you go. So yeah,
some monkeys like that, but the SA, the joint warfare, Krill oil,
these are for your joints. Keep your joints in the game if you're for real,
getting after it like especially in the gym and doing Jujitsu,
man knows the joint warfarin.
The krill oil is gonna keep you in the game big times. Can help you out a lot.
Huge time. As we say, don't forget about the warrior kid milk as well. Yeah.
Which is,
which is tasty and why not feed your kids something that's actually going to be
good for them instead of feeding them literal poison. Yeah.
Gummy bears. Yeah. Sugar for sure. Crap. Unless yes,
and discipline as well.
If he wants some cognitive enhancing elements infused into your brain,
get some discipline. That's a good one.
Get yourself some Jocko white tea as well. Yeah.
That's if you want to have a massive dead lift in excess of 8,000 pounds.
Check. Yeah. Also it's certified organic.
So that's something also we have a store, it's called Choco store.
You can get the tee on the store. Two, we have the t on the store. Um,
but also on the store dollar store.com.
This is where you can get a shirts if you want to represent on the path.
Discipline equals freedom. Even get after it. You know, simple stuff.
I chose quality over cheap quantity.
Sure. So when you get the shirt should be as it should be, right?
So if you get this shirt and you recognize that, Dang this,
this could very well be my favorite shirt just to wear just the fit in the
field. The shirt, I won't be surprised. In fact, I'd be surprised if it's not.
That's my opinion. And the last is good stuff on there.
There's rash guards on there, some hats,
flex fit and snapback trucker hats, some hoodies,
lightweight and heavyweight. Some good stuff on there. Anyway,
if you want something, get something. It is juggle store.com also,
don't forget to subscribe to this podcast if you want to go ahead and smash the
subscribe button. I'm, we're not doing that anymore. I'll go over.
That was the last one. Last one. Alright.
No more [inaudible] you can click the subscribe button.
Yeah, I guess,
I guess if you're going to remind someone to do something in regards to
subscribing,
it'd be more on the youtube thing to do the notification bell if they want to be
notified because that's not just a given when you subscribe. I don't know.
Some people might not know that this is what I'm saying. Okay.
I'm definitely a more person that did not know that. All right,
well there you go. Please subscribe. Whatever Twitter or not Twitter, sorry,
stitcher, Google play, iTunes, that kind of stuff. Yeah. Yeah.
Also don't forget to work. Keep podcasts. Three new releases,
24 25 and 26 boom.
Including an interview with John Bozek, the illustrator,
the drawer of pictures of all the worry kid books,
including Mikey and the dragons. So anyway, yeah. Very interesting on that one,
especially if you're into any kind of creative thing.
It kind of demonstrates the door, talks about the process and the frustration.
It's good.
I actually liked it a lot also where he could soap,
Irish, oops. Ranch dot competence where you can get Jocko soap trooper.
So all made by warrior kid Aiden in the United States. By the way,
does he have some kind of motto or anything like that? Yeah, like it's a slogan,
slogan, stay clean. Sorry. Battle.
Say it all like crazy like you whatever. But best stay clean.
Simple to the point, right? Yeah. All good. I was not impressed with,
I know your job. They're doing the best they can. Anyway,
like I mentioned, we have a youtube channel as well. [inaudible] podcasts,
youtube channel. If you are interested in the video version of this, uh,
this here situation, um, and some excerpts on there,
some enhanced excerpts on there too. If you want to look at them,
it's good psychological warfare. It's out there. iTunes, Google play MP3,
get it.
Don't forget about the visual versions of psychological warfare from side
canvas.com which is run by my brother, Dakota Meyer.
You might want to check that one out as well. Yeah. Discipline equals freedom
art. Yeah. Yeah. We, we have posters, right? Which is cool. Like, you know,
you hang them in your gym and whatever, but it's like one, two,
maybe three levels higher than the poster is like, you know,
can you hang on your wall in your home, in your office? Clearly you could,
you can put these things up. They are legit.
And we've got some warrior kid posters, uh,
Art Coleman as well cause they're not just posters. They're like, they're like,
yeah, the quality also on it, on
it.com/jocko go there, click on it this weekend. Get what kettlebells,
like fitness stuff. I'm seeing, you know, some cool supplements, some Greens,
some food items, you know. Well this is where I get my kettlebells actually.
Yeah. Like pretty much all my home gym stuff.
Aside from like the dumb bells set I get from on it.
All of it when they're on it.com/jocko get something and got some books too.
I've written a bunch of them. Weigh the warrior kid where there's a [inaudible]
well number. That's number three of that book that is live,
so get that for your kid.
Also get the way the where your kid won and way the warrior kid too,
which is called Mark's mission.
These books are good and these are the books I wish I had when I was a kid.
They would just put me on the path at a younger age. Mikey and the dragons.
You can order that one now as well.
That is for a little bit younger age. Maybe three, four, five, six,
sure. Through 70 yeah, I would agree with that. Yeah.
I just want to go street and field manual [inaudible]
all the little questions that you want to ask me about everything.
Our answer is answered in that book. The discipline equals freedom field manual.
How to get after it. The audio version is not on audible,
it's on iTunes. It's on Amazon. Music, it's on Google play.
Other mp3s and those are questions that you might have about life,
about my personal operating system. If you have questions about leadership,
checkout, extreme ownership and the dichotomy of leadership.
I referenced them both today and I referenced them all the time written by me
and my brother Leif Babin about the experiences we had overseas and how you can
take those experiences and apply them to the leadership in your life and world.
We also have echelon front, which is our leadership consultancy.
We solve problems through leadership.
You can go to echelon front.com for details on that.
If you want to get some additional training online,
you go to f online.com and that's where we have all the echelon front
instructors teaching classes, online interactive classes.
Check that one out if you want to go more granular and then we have the monster
which is a conference, a gathering, a leadership gathering.
The next one is in Denver,
September 19th and 20th and then in Sydney, Australia,
December 4th and fifth check extreme ownership.com for all of the musters have
sold out and these will too. So get there early.
And of course we have EMF, Overwatch where we are
taking
spec ops and Combi combat aviation leaders and placing them into civilian
companies that need leader ship e f overwatch.com if you want to hire someone
from special operations or your former special operations and you would like to
work in the civilian sector, go to Yaffe, overwatch.com follow the instructor.
And so we will hook it up and if you feel like you want to cruise with us just a
little bit more, you can find us both on the Inter webs
on Twitter,
on Instagram and on DVA is a book echo is adequate.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink and thanks to all of you that make this
podcast possible. First,
those of you in the armed services who put your honor and duty above yourselves
and protect freedom around the world and to all the police officers and law
enforcement, to the firefighters, the paramedics, the EMT, [inaudible],
the dispatchers, the correctional officers, the border patrol,
secret service, and all the other first responders.
Each of you do the same.
You placed the welfare of others above the welfare of yourself in order to keep
us safe. So thanks for what you do
and the rest of you that are out there,
thanks for the support that you all give us.
You are the fuel that keeps this train moving.
Yeah.
Literally, we appreciate it. And also remember this,
no matter what happened in the past,
you control the narrative.
Okay?
You write the story that you want to write.
You give yourself the role that you want. Make your
fonts in that story filled with discipline
and make your actions,
make them nothing short of heroic.
Then step out into the world and get after it
that until next time, this is echo and Jocko.